He was like, I believe in you, Doki.
He actually gave me hope.
All right.
Serious question.
How much do you want to win this today?
I mean, I'd like to win.
Like a hundred, like, I don't know, bro.
A million percent, please.
I need you to know, Chad, I put, I done at least 500.
games within two weeks i know i know you've played a lot
despite despite how much turmoil you have put me through up
up to this point so far i put you you know how much turmoil
rake has put me i mean let that anchor out on someone that
is insane work
anyway i i love street fighters I did.
I gave it to him.
But I put CarQ first and he's not here.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
Okay, I need to set up my stream.
All right, listen.
All I want to say is I'm broke and I really would like this
money.
So if you all can lock the fuck in.
Wait, okay, how much have you practiced, though?
Dude, I asked Shine.
Ask Shine.
Shine is like, are you available for an emergency coaching
session?
Because no one else wants to do it?
I'm like, sure, man.
Literally the day of my flight.
I was flying out in like three hours.
And I was doing a practice stream with Shine.
See, that's passion right there.
Passion.
That's passion.
Passion and being broke.
Yeah.
That's what I call it.
I was asking Shine.
I was like, hey, I'm ready for coaching.
You know what I see him on?
2XKO.
That's what I saw him.
But where's the passion?
What do you mean?
I get I You know I was up at like 8 a.m.
7 a.m.
Helping you because you need emergency coaching There's the
passion right there Yeah, emergency coaching Yeah, she
always hit me up to like I'm hard stuck 24-7 on call for me
Why?
Why weren't you there 24-7 She messaged me at 4 a.m.
like I'm hard stuck Like what?
okay well it's car queue first i don't know if they invite
you already yeah what up team sorry sorry i'm here though
i'm ready i'm locked you're good nice to be sure good luck
thank you i got this yeah it's okay i'm last so i also i'm
gonna stuffy it's okay you're gonna pop off i'm gonna
believe in you a hundred percent i'll make it look like at
least i tried and if it doesn't look like tried at you know
look at her is higher ranked than me there is dude i know
like what what
don't look at it don't look at that it doesn't matter they
played a thousand five hundred games in in a week in a way
no in two weeks yes i got them i got them don't worry i'll
get them i'll get Oh, God.
All right, you got him.
He's a speedrunner.
He's built different.
One thousand games?
Yeah.
Honestly, thank God that we are home for this one.
Yeah, I mean, they're not going to Japan.
Oh, wait.
Feistin, I beat Karku, and he could have gone to Japan.
I'm sorry, Karku.
You could have gone.
I mean, Karku robbed me of my trip to Japan, so it was a
little bit of karma.
Oh, that's karma.
Yeah.
and you pick him and you pick him i thought he'd bring that
same energy you know like you know he has some like destiny
oh to be fair all three of us all three of us have been to
the japan too to be fair he tried to he tried to theory
craft here if we can't beat him draft them yeah but in the
end
fucked up oh I got the invite all right let's get it oh my
god are you are you able to share your screen in Discord as
well Clarkie I think so yeah let me see if it'll lag me
really quick probably not though uh just because so I can
get a bit more of a live feed uh when I expected through
here it's a little it's a little late oh yeah with a little
bit of a delay yeah yeah it's a little the delay so i'll be
able to help you in like real time yeah he's gonna tell you
to press a button you're already knocked down that that is
that is typically what would happen yes oh my god me up
first all right yeah you're first yeah you're first you're
kicking it off no no pressure no pressure no pressure no
creativity this way it's less pressure than being last
because if we are tied and i'm the deciding factor we are
not going to No, you I heard you're cold.
I hold your actual ice in your veins, though, so I've heard.
You're about to sell on them all.
Wait, are you also on the Honda?
No, I'm not on Honda.
I'm on my.
Because I'm not, it's not going to work against Kony.
It's not going to work against it.
It will, I promise.
It's two a day.
I already invested two weeks on my.
All right.
We're waiting.
Oh, yeah.
we can't swear because we're on stream yeah just remember we
can swear right now oh we're but i thought oh when we're
fighting right we can't swear no because we're on stream so
they're not getting our feed they get yeah they have okay so
when we're on stream we can go wild basically i think so
yeah but i mean i mean in your case maybe you should just
keep it consistent Yeah, maybe on your stream, or you, Doki,
maybe you should just be consistent.
No, maybe you need to get practice.
If I hold it in.
Do you want us to mute?
No, I'm good.
I'm all for, like, hyping and yapping in the background.
I don't get distracted by that.
So I'm chilling.
All right, here we go.
Good luck.
Thank you.
Medium punch.
Okay.
Okay, use that.
Oh.
I like the dry rush medium punch, dude.
Okay, I got a careful up right now.
Nice.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Yeah, remember the headbuttals.
Yeah, we wake up with those.
He's not ready for that.
He's not ready for the butt slings either.
Oh, I should have crouched, right?
That would have worked.
Yeah, yeah, that's fine.
Nice.
Okay, I gotta stop doing the chop for the...
Yeah, remember headbutt is good for that.
Right, right, right, right.
Oh, I thought she was going for a throw.
No, that's fine.
I should just take him to throw instead of gambling.
All right, all right, all right.
Let it ride.
Yeah, keep gambling.
Yeah.
You know what?
Yeah, maybe more.
I'm a gambling man.
I'm down.
I'm going to go.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, this is what we need.
This is where we need.
This is the learning game.
This is the warm-up, you know?
Points don't matter in this one.
He's always dragging you after the head.
blood so maybe press a button
maybe stop gambling i don't know you can switch sides like
that okay yeah she can do that in like the corner okay
understandable okay i think you should spam more blood slam
i'm in i'll take that oh my god whoa don't let that
discourage you though i think you should go yeah yeah you're
you're a honda player that's nice we need more command grabs
you're right you're right that that works now we do it yes
yes oh my god whoa leg oh yes nice nice we like that nice
nice okay that was a gamble yeah yeah careful foot oh shit
whoa whoa leg going on there oh my Oh, the lag!
No!
The lag!
Okay, free match.
No, you're good.
We're super laggy.
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know what's happening.
I don't know what's going on here.
Oh, five frames.
Yeah, since it's so laggy, just do stuff because he can't
react to it.
He's not going to react to butt slam.
Oh, I try to crouch, but...
The lag.
Nice.
no escape i like that nice you might do level three here i'm
not that right oh no you're not dead you have like a sliver
you're not burnt out either okay uh well just wake up di oh
yeah it's okay it's okay they lagged which they cheated yeah
i don't know why that was so laggy yeah that's weird and
that was warm up would that have worked there uh i i think
um i don't think it would have worked um but when they're in
brain i was probably not a bad idea they would have been
forced to block it though for sure all right i think i go in
there now yes might be bring it back bring it back yeah yeah
yeah give me a yeah let me close yours real quick let me
open the other one good Yeah, legitimately, what's the, when
you're like, when you're outclassed by 10 times, what's the
advice here?
What do I do here?
Just shoot fireballs.
Yeah, you just gotta shoot fireballs and try to jumpers.
He's probably gonna throw fireball.
Yeah.
At some point.
You're just gonna bubble, bubble, bubble.
Do you want us to mute?
No, no, no.
I like the chatter.
You are all really encouraging.
Okay.
I really appreciate it, actually.
just keep saying fireball fireball fireball yeah you just
got to be careful she throws a an ex one but just remember
you have your ex one as well okay i like it nice
don't be afraid to jump at them either yeah get some tiger
knees in there duck that out it's okay she doesn't know i'll
play gistagat it's so rare in that elo i
like the idea but yeah just
yeah remember to throw some more fireballs don't forget
about the fireballs
i got a couple of hits in that's good that was good that's
good just remember this person had like basically there we
go 18 times yeah now we're now we're sagat gaming now we're
sagatting yeah remember when he starts to approach after
that get ready to
okay so they just did the plan to me that i have to them yes
i did the same thing yeah that was good that was good that's
good yeah just remember to use the low the low fireball
because she can't crawl under them and then she's gonna try
to approach and try to jump at you that's when you just and
tired okay don't be afraid to like jump in and throw some
dis out too you know
we need more fireballs okay man she's got a move that goes
straight through them yeah or there you go close close yeah
yeah nice like that nice oh my god you're half hp damage
halfway there halfway there exactly oh my god one third
you're so big that she doesn't know which one's upper and
which one's lower that's my problem too
Nice.
Combos!
I like that.
Don't be afraid when they're in burnout to do DI as well.
Okay, we gotta get some Antires.
They're jumping a lot at you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Honestly, I'm gonna be honest with you, Shine, I pressed the
wrong button.
Oh yeah, it's fine.
You gotta remember which button it is.
Yeah, I pressed my old DI button.
I feel like she could have punished me a couple of times
there.
She's gonna definitely on this one.
Nice.
Nice prediction.
that's some speedrunner tech right there oh
you can do that okay I feel like I feel like I got him no no
I got him if I got two more rounds I got this yeah yeah all
right so here's the thing I'm typically I'm throwing two
fireballs before they jump in right this guy jumps in after
one so I feel like I every time I just should have done a
chore you can read up to the fireball yeah I mean he always
jumps in once he's in range you just have to kind of watch
out for it low fireballs are hitting him a lot that's when
he's when he's ready to like when he's walking towards you
that's when you have to start uh looking for them you also
did like spammy no doubt that was super spammy all right
anyway you're up smile can i play already uh yeah he's he's
on there yeah i think i think you just go up next do we i
don't think they said good to start right
production i believe i believe in you they'll let you know
when you're good to start they didn't say it yet okay so
freeward's watching what's cool about this if his feisty
wins were tied this is going for 20 points instead of 10.
this could tie it up here that's true that's true and that's
why true that's why i told shine i didn't want to be last
that's no you're you're you'll be fine no
I just want y'all to know that I don't deal well with
pressure.
Nah, you deal great with pressure.
Wait, no, you won the last, during the last tournament.
You won with pressure.
Yeah, and it wasn't it like last game, last round or
something?
Yeah, last round, one HP.
Yeah, whatever.
Anyway, lock you.
No, you're good.
You're good to go.
Trust, you're about to cook right now.
All right, well, she prefers everyone to like, you know,
mute, by the way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But if you want to hype me up between rounds...
No, go ahead.
Oh my god.
Yeah, guys, but like the first game I always get super
nervous.
That's why I really didn't want to go last play last because
like, Bricky is like the same elo as me and so I had the
most chance to get a round up.
But really, I wish it wasn't Bricky first because I always
play really bad on the first game.
that's why i was just like okay if he if he if you see him
doing like charge heavy punch too you can wait for and try
to di remember you can back dash every now and then try to
get him to with it i'm just gonna play how i usually play
and if if it doesn't work it doesn't work Oh my god.
I'm gonna level three here.
That's fine, yeah.
Just watch for his level three.
Just be careful.
Yeah.
But I really...
I wish I wasn't doing less.
Okay.
That was clutch.
much like you but now he has ca it's all right that was sick
that was i know i can't psych myself up but you guys know me
it's harder because it's a 1v1 scenario it's not like a team
thing where i could be like i did my part but now i'm like
if i don't do my part it's so obvious
nice that's our two-pointer that's the two-pointer in 20.
oh good no he's playing good maybe maybe a little bit when
you when you do uh when you do run stop too uh be careful
doing the overhead so much like he's clearly not like doing
anything there so maybe you can do run stop until like
crouch jab or run stop into like throw instead a little bit
more okay yeah he's just kind of blocking the overhead every
time so and then after you're putting yourself in bad spots
where you have to guess so be careful of that or at least
just do the run and just let him do it you know what i mean
oh my cannot oh god yeah it's all right just just use the
in-game spectator yeah don't worry about it don't worry
about it don't worry
don't worry oh this is scary thanks i i can never watch
street fighter like like not seriously but like watching
street fighter gets me so nervous and i'm not even playing
it it's not good for my heart come on now what that was good
i was good what do you mean that's intense i even watching
street fighter gets me your cookie this is way too anxious
and i'm not even playing nice
it's just way too stressful i get way too anxious watching i
haven't drink i only drink coffee when i started the day i
didn't drink coffee after that i just get super anxious
watching street fighter let it come back you don't gotta
rush it if it's on my team obviously if i'm like watching
random people like it's fine but like i'm watching my own
team and it get like oh my heart just goes like
There you go.
See, I was good.
I felt you getting antsy a little bit, but you actually sat
back and got your meter back.
Yeah, just keep playing like this.
It's solid.
You're good.
Nice.
I wish I could do that.
That's why I'll never be masked.
I don't think I could ever do anything related to this.
That's all right.
That's fine.
Oh, that's all right.
Yeah, no, that's fine.
It's all right.
Sometimes, sometimes you...
You know, you got to do that.
It just didn't work out, but it's fine.
Got a little puenksy.
That's me when I play too much rank.
I just, I start deteriorating.
I was like, I think I was like two games away from ranking
up to plat three.
And then I just, I started, I lost my eighth game win
streak.
And then I just start playing angry.
It's better to take this early than later.
then i dropped like 400 points um he's gonna drive rich at
you
yeah and i just started like playing way too aggressive
because i got way i got too angry
oh oh my god oh yeah you're good that's fine that's fine you
got this that one round
how's grab that much damage it's in deep but that's why he's
like like he has to play super passive not i mean not
passive but you know what i mean like he has to always get
close which is hard there's one more just stay solid oh if i
see up a little bit okay I brought Faisy up a little.
Sound guy is not alive.
Oh my god.
Like, I like it.
I like it.
Oh my god, why?
There.
Why?
Why did that come out like that?
I was just trying to do medium or light level one.
You don't gotta worry about that anymore.
Oh my god, this combo never ends.
nice hold on she's cooking she's cooking did it i'm 20
pointer oven preheated wow hang on let's go oh god i see my
string bugging out yeah yeah that's all about to say i was
like i didn't want to distract you with it but we were we
were in we were actually in danger yeah i'm legitimate
danger are you ready to fight or do i wait wait wait wait no
no no no no no sorry no sorry no sorry uh they'll give you
the okay and this word all right well i was good though
feisty i thought you played that really well and yeah i was
trying one you know i was trying not to freak out you know
yeah because i i think geef too like when you freak out
against geef that's when you tend to just play risky like i
like the drive rushes but then the drive rushes work because
you're also passive.
No, the dry rushes work because you're playing a little bit
more passive, which is fine.
Like when you play against Gief normally, you just like
face, you just face plant into them when every other
character you play, you play solid.
So, but yeah, you're playing solid against Gief too, which
is good.
That was good.
Let me know when they say yes, I'm not looking at the chat.
Oh my God.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
that was solid you would just like driver bus like he was in
that corner for most of the game i feel like yeah that was
crazy of all the matches that was nice yeah that's exactly
where we want to keep geef if you can but then you get
perfect parry he back through you and then you have a heart
attack yeah i knew he was in a perfect pair too when i did
the drive rush crouch and light kick because i feel like he
always perfect parries there yeah but i did it anyway i
don't really know i mean it's fine oh okay you're good to
start i up the volume a little oh sorry uh all right i'm
going in yeah be one thing i want you to i want to warn you
of though be careful doing your auto heavy and and uh
because number one it is safe and two they were definitely
practicing how to punish that so auto heavy okay do you want
us to talk or no i don't know honestly we'll see how it
We'll see how it goes.
Oh.
I'm burnt out.
It's alright.
That's fine.
Just do the thing.
I can't get my settings right here.
Yep.
That's fine.
You can just sit back and wait for it to come back.
You don't have to go do anything crazy.
Alright.
Nice.
I like it.
Level one.
oh whoops that was not what i wanted to do but i can do this
oh no no i pressed my special it's all right that was a good
round though
yep yep you expand get in there nice i like that
Oh.
Fuck.
I'll take it.
That's good.
No, that's fine.
That's fine.
All right.
Just, yep.
When, when you block those, uh, those like, flip kicks
there, do auto like.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
No!
It's all right.
Yeah, that was pretty hard because you don't have DI to
return anyway.
You would have had to be ready to do super.
You got this.
Nice.
No, okay, it's fine.
No, no, you got it.
Good stuff.
Oh, come on.
Nice.
That's all right.
nope just throw some fans stood back
what no oh no i think he blocks it he blocks it sorry i like
the idea though honestly i think we need to block a little
more on wake up you know if he knocks you down just block oh
wow
oh my gosh what nice good punish what just wait yeah that
would have been awkward for you to figure out how to punish
nice good neutral jump oh I should have what
yeah the box yeah she She doesn't have any meter, so she
can't DI you, so you don't have to be scared of that right
now.
I think that kills.
Nice, nice.
Yes, that does kill.
Yeah, when she's burnt out, you don't got to worry about DI.
You can kind of chill a little bit, yeah.
Nice.
I keep getting fucked over by that.
If you're trying to do forward special to anti-air, it's not
considered an anti-air.
You'd have to do the metered version.
So try neutral jumping a little bit more.
Yeah, you can DI.
Ooh, we got one.
We got one.
Okay, it's fine.
Even if we lose this, I counter DI.
I have never been more proud.
Oh.
I said she was going to bust him out on finals day two.
What a...
Does that kill him?
What a punish!
That kills him!
That kills him.
Let's go.
That was so good.
that was so good okay focus on diying that special move you
know what's the special the the air flip kick thing that she
does that keeps that keeps hitting you yeah nice okay you
can di it
okay throw some more fans maybe nice oh no fuck i'm sorry
I want to throw her, but...
Yeah, yeah, it's just a little bit missed time, it's fine.
Block this.
Nice.
So I want you to just charge regular fans.
Yeah, not EX, just charge these, yeah.
And then you can go in after them.
Okay.
No.
I can't charge anymore.
Ah, I fucked up!
That's alright.
Maybe try to jump in on him a bit more.
I don't know if he can answer that.
Nice.
She's going to be burnt out here too.
So they can't DI you.
Oh.
Nice.
But I'm burnt out too though.
No, that's all right.
That's
all right.
Throw him.
When you, yeah.
Oh.
Yeah, I can't do it.
anything right now all right it's fine you expand no oh
unfortunate if you pressed the button you would have gotten
it but he didn't oh sorry i pressed rem okay ah i should
have that was good though i saw him jump so then i went for
it i mean you didn't you didn't uh what's it called you
weren't wrong he just actually just didn't press a button
had he pressed the button you would have actually gotten
that antire there yeah that was good and we got the counter
di yeah we got the counter di at least we got we got one
counter di under under massive pressure last if i wasn't
last to be fine i mean honestly if you were if you were a
second it still would have been wouldn't have been fine
either no it would have been it would have been easier on me
if i would it would me but we all got to watch you do uh
yeah that's true i got counter di under under all of that
pressure which i took a round off that was my goal i took a
round off he had one year he had almost two years on chun
lee i had two weeks on my you're popping off though i saw
those combos oh my that was good though that was really good
yeah i'm gonna brb for five minutes remember thing was like
lagging i think it like auto updated again so that's
happening again oh that whole stutter was on me i wasn't
even oh i see i started yeah my game was just on reaction i
have to they said i have a few like minutes before the next
one i'll be your be i should i should i should have autoed
special that but i was like i it was no it's sick though
pure reaction i'm surprised so so to get you to counter di
we just have to put you under massive amounts of pressure no
is that is that what it is not it's because i practiced it's
because i actually practice counter d are you are you sure
yes are you sure we don't have to put you out no enormous
amounts of pressure not true in fact mentally breaking
pressure if you didn't put me enormous amount of pressure i
could have won that i i think i could have won that if you
think so i don't know i think i think pressure brings out
the best in your capability no i made a lot of mistakes I
would never make when I was doing practice really I thought
you were playing pretty good though no I know no no it would
have been even better I would play it even better all right
when is our next match or do we have plenty of time till our
next one time because they're still playing upstream all
right I'm gonna practice then all right guys I'm gonna watch
Beckman fight against now then i don't know bro you look all
right viper viper alex only viper alex only come join right
wait who's next wait who are we playing next does anyone
know i'm trying to find i don't know man i'm trying to find
the thing that they gave us yeah the uh order and stuff
honestly it's not that bad at least we have 20 points yeah
you know 20 20 is better than nothing that's what i'm saying
they only 10 points ahead of us exactly exactly technically
it's like we won two matches yeah yeah yeah does anyone know
who we're playing up next so i know what to practice against
next um shine we'll see i'm trying to find i'm trying to
find a group where i just forgot where they gave me the
thing and i think it was on it was on general i think
general we fight jb team yeah yeah yeah jb i just found it
as you all right which is um guys i couldn't do the dash run
the dash throw combo because chun lee kept um the chun lee
kept uh uh anti like at um kept like they're anti-airing it
so i just stopped doing it was up triangle so now it's just
like uh well i can't do anything about it so
bro bro probably thought that i play like a bitch and i did
i mean you're against zen keep of course you'd play you have
to play like a bitch you would be right i was playing we're
playing so busy are we playing against jb um yeah all right
guys alex only alex only you remember that this is an
off-stream match that we will be playing yeah and i would
passion okay i guess we lose then what do you mean well i
mean your your ability to play is tied to your ability yes i
win yes okay honestly same all right well what do we know
about skull vulgar um i i actually don't know oh my god
shine just that's what i'm up against skull vulgar she's
just she's just waiting for a reason to say i'm a bad coach
but she knows she doesn't mean it i mean it i feel like if
you really wanted her to go to orlando and get that money
you would have learned who skull vulgar is i see that's what
i'm saying like i will see he's playing in my face i will
see we both got went all three of us have gone to japan and
shine wasn't coaching us
and be right back also was japan nice was it at least a cool
trip oh did she leave already yeah sorry i'm getting my ass
beat by alex right now i'm japan was great it was great well
yeah it is modern beef and i think is modern my sorry oh
my chat seems i forgot what i wanted to say is that right
wait i think skull was either skull oh skull is thank you if
he plays thank you okay okay yeah see shine i'm doing your
job what do you mean i already knew that we all we all
already discussed this and found this out already i don't
think i can do what feisty did feisty just like ran up and
slapped his belly i don't think i can like a dude that stuff
against theinflation you know what i mean i'm only going to
be throwing fireballs well i mean if you're playing sagata
that's what you're supposed to do so you you pick the right
character for it sorry that doesn't count that doesn't count
i was distracted halfway guys i that was distracted halfway
that doesn't count i literally didn't play half the game
Guys, I will say, I will say, guys, where were my Chun-Li's
when during practice?
Why is it all Alex?
Does nobody play Chun-Li?
I think Chun-Li was the rarest.
What is happening?
Yeah, one out of 80 Alex's.
Oh, I had 80 Alex's and one Chun-Li.
Oops, all Alex.
No, you guys don't understand.
I had one at one or two Chun-Lis out of 80 Alex's.
Loki do still feel like you're probably going to get bison
though, feisty.
No, I don't think I'm going to get bison.
Really?
Yeah, I don't think so.
I don't think...
I don't think her bison is sharp enough.
I don't think so.
Maybe Alex, but I don't think I don't think bison.
Oh, yeah, I forgot to tell you about Alex.
Alex, when you see him go in a prowler stance, I tend to
just do the slide, by the way.
It helps a lot.
Like if you stay at a range where if he goes in a prowler
stance and you slide and you hit him it's pretty good to
stop him from just autopiloting that you know what i mean
yeah like you just stand you just stand kind of close and if
you see him going to power stance you just kind of like
slide even if he does like an early stomp you kind of slide
under him you don't gotta deal with it okay i
just only had enough experiences against chisney i think
that was
because i always forget like what her movesets were i'm
watching bet mine she's uh the one playing on that team
right now and then i think there's one more match and then
we play them because i forget like the combo string where
like i have to figure out like my biggest issue when i don't
know the character that well is i don't know if i could
block low or high so when she was doing that like
cross-legged block thing i didn't know if i was supposed to
if i can and i keep forgetting if i could anti-air block low
or oh my god he actually anti-air yes i didn't wouldn't have
expected that was like my biggest issue a little bad like
you saw one anti-air in your shook i didn't want it oh no
he's not dead oh my god wow sorry it's very too late damn i
wonder how the how that i just didn't realize chudley is so
unpopular why is she so unpopular probably best if they go
80 alexes yeah but i don't know i don't know who's winning
i'll never win against him i i joined into this late so it's
hard to tell that's the worst part i thought 80 alexes i'm
not gonna win let me ask maybe i'll ask
She's more popular in Fortnite.
No, Broke, but it's not you.
It's just I didn't have a lot of practice with her.
Yeah, I asked her.
She's too thick to handle.
She is.
I'm sorry.
Let me...
I get...
It's because Alex is shirtless.
Sorry, today I'm like extra.
I'm like, today I'm like extra, extra right now.
It might be, oh, I'm not too mean.
I'm just, it's just banter.
Uh-huh.
I'm extra passionate.
Bro, these are two diamond players, man.
What is this?
watching now who should i pull up well i'm still watching
back mine but it's um ricky and connie blaine you can pull
up the capcom i think they're streaming it on camp no i lied
they're not streaming it on camera please get me out of here
just kill me yeah i lied i'm sorry just kill me
uh the double turning mental hey i got i got my one though i
got a round off like these people no combos bro this is so
crazy you know like they're both going classic classic viper
and classic alex and they're doing like crazy combos like
it's cold he wants to smash bro feisty that was just fair i
just don't understand bro this is not fair at all like look
at this yeah i mean the selection of tears was is also like
i thought this whole thing was going to be like goofs you
know no no it's not we're sweating everybody's sweating
these tournaments are always sweaty they're always people
will play like 50 plus hours in like like and that's like
minimum if i get back in i'll prep i will do more prep i
thought we'd be just goofing off you know no no no No, well,
it's me Kony didn't practice a lot, but also he's already a
fighting game player So like he already has the fundamentals
and everything and he got like Automatic tier he got like
high rank in Tekken as well.
I don't remember what the high rank was Like in two weeks or
some shit
Can I ask a dumb question the team is um is Sagat's suit?
Is that like too basic at this point?
Does everybody just wear the suit?
wait what happened what what should what costume should i
put on sagat is my question uh i mean the suit is the newest
one and that one looks good for vibes i think most people i
mean i like the suit i always use the suit at least now i do
i was trying to predict i thought he was gonna i thought he
was gonna di me because he died me every other time
all right
Oh, now you DI me!
Now you DI!
They're sweating over there.
Okay.
Oh,
there we go.
Oh, get fucking predicted, you whore!
It's okay, I'm not on stream yet.
I'm getting it out right now.
Yeah, Doki, I don't know how you're gonna be either of them.
That's what...
That's what I'm saying!
Why am I here?
Shine!
why did you do this to me what do you mean i didn't do
anything to you you picked me you need to take this up with
cap if i wasn't gonna pick you someone else would have
picked you you know what i mean like we went off you gotta
take this up confidence you gotta take this up with capcom i
this is not my doing you know why did you put me through
this i did not put you through you gotta take this up with
capcom this is not me
I'm just put here to suffer.
It's alright, suffering can be vibes.
I could try and do this to me.
oh they are really trying they're going to last game last
round it looks like yeah it is serious yeah they're there's
very guys i think they're gonna put me as the 20 pointer i i
think they were gonna do that to me i i mean i think they
might put kyle not yeah probably maybe i think you'd be free
not to you gotta take you gotta take your 20 points where
you can get them you know Wait, we have to play JB next,
right?
I think, hmm.
Yeah, I think I think you might it might be you doku.
Yeah, sorry.
Don't get I think you can do this, but like I think you need
to like be toss more fans.
Like we have to worry about tossing fans more.
There's a couple of times where what the what are they
doing?
I don't know.
damn so begmont team also has 20 so now we're gonna lose to
jb team and then whoa whoa no no it's okay slow down there
hold on what we can do this we can do this maybe i'll i'm
gonna pull a miracle i'm fighting you gotta you gotta be a
fighter i'm not a fighter man i'm literally a giver upper
bro i'm ready to give up every single time I'm like fighting
80 Alex's it should be fine I'm always ready to give up bro
always oh now I get a Chun Li I'm sorry I'm so passionate
today I'm so sorry how's my run going I'm gonna give her up
her bro I said that that's how it's going joking yeah going
good I think need more Alex I'm going to an Alex chocolate I
fought 80 Alex's 10 vipers and one Chen Lee
okay so skull vulver plays zangief yeah that's what that's
what you said earlier did you because uh you couldn't figure
it out wait wait yes I said that earlier I had to say it but
you gaslighted me you we can we can go back to the vods you
gaslighted me i definitely said modern geef before you i'm
starting to think just no one listens to me maybe that's the
real problem here it was eventual though you eventually got
to gain zanke yeah but my dog is angry too modern modern
geef and someone said ingrid i don't know who said ingrid
but i said modern geef
that's not too bad we can just fireballs yeah we can
fireball that that's that's winnable that's very winnable we
fireball it up we can raid the anti-air and we're good just
uh they do the spin right so if you try to fireball and
they'll start doing that like a little tornado spin right
yeah but that they they can't move forward when they do it
so it's not it's not a huge issue for you yeah the main
thing you gotta worry about of how he's gonna try and get
bypass your fireballs is probably his uh jumps or his uh di
oh my god yeah because right i guess i guess even if he does
that crazy attack where he throws his arms up and runs at
you the fireball beats that yeah if you see that it'll slow
him down but you do still have to jump to avoid that So just
be careful.
If you see his arms up, just neutral jump, land, and then do
auto-heavy.
Stop!
Okay, now you countered DI.
I'm just playing angry now.
I'm just playing angry.
I'm just mad.
I don't care if I waste it.
I'm angry.
today is an angry day they're about to start inviting us
soon I mean I guess they choose the order so it's whatever
you know it's whatever is whatever they
choose okay okay I'll calm down I calm down I'm calming down
question why do they ask for our characters probably for the
overlay And also so good that it's a just a blind pick.
Cody won't do that though.
I guess if you two join the lobby and you have a character
queued up, they can just kind of count.
Oh my gosh.
So I think they asked for that.
So you guys can't like counter pick each other all day.
It's just a blind pick essentially.
But all right.
Did I get an invite yet?
Let me see.
Oh, I did not.
Why can I only spectate?
Let me leave.
Okay.
All right.
It's okay.
My dog's angry.
I'm angry.
Maybe I did say what Chad just said, but I did say modern
geef, though.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I did say it.
You're clear.
In my book, you're clear.
We know what I'm up against, and you told me what I have to
be prepared for to handle.
I think we should be good smile yeah but yeah I think I
think you might be the 20 point dokey but oh my god either
that or Kyle honestly I I would hope it's Kyle I think you
think I wish it would be Kyle just hold you know I don't
have to get my ass beat three times in a row it would be
very nice if i don't have to go through that i don't want
kony to beat me up i mean i don't know how come the coaches
aren't playing i need shine to just whoop everybody they put
kyle i'm sorry kyle i'm sorry but first so but you play
first though dokey so i mean that's fine get it over with i
just get it over with that's fine I, that's fine.
It's what I wanted.
Just murder me now.
Nah, you're about to cook.
I just got CI 80 times.
I think you're about to cook, right?
Right?
Yeah, no, no, no.
I'm about to cook right now.
I'll focus up when I'm there.
Confident.
Don't worry.
I got DI'd.
Do not worry.
Oh, I see.
It's okay.
Someone told me they did a stat analyzation on Kony, and he
only DI's 10% of his matches.
Nice.
Yeah, so make sure we DI him, you know, just play, just, I
want, I want some very high vibes-based gameplay.
Nope.
Got DI'd.
Oh, I'm in the, I'm in the.
the wrong lobby oh my god wait are we starting now all right
give me a sec i'm in a cut scene i'm in an alex cut scene
yeah i didn't get one either oh that's why they're waiting
for let's see they don't want me to be in there and
counterpick with the character or something okay so we
should in that group chat we should just say what our
characters are um i'm sending it right now okay wait do i do
i play another custom match or are we going in we're booting
in oh i got an invite just now as i said that yeah yeah yeah
i'll wait right now grab my left side you you guys a job
just to make sure feisty plays what does that mean feisty
thank you for it thank you for being let me on your we got
we got to put you to work you know you can't just wish i was
first bro i don't want to be last this sucks i don't i don't
get i know it sucks doesn't it yes it does suck she was on
the other foot now away away maybe you're up to something
huh maybe he was right well i mean can you share your screen
again oh yeah i share screen
Who's last anyway?
What do you mean?
As long as it's not me.
Everyone should have a turn being last.
We should give everyone an equal chance being last.
Technically we can, because the next two games, we're home.
Oh, true.
oh my gosh my okay wait okay okay i hope they don't start
because i think i might need to feed my dog i'll be right
back i might have to feed my dog she might that dog is
starving dude dog is literally please master please win your
street fighter match dog is in the gates
Oh, no, they don't they don't know Doki's not ready.
Oh, yeah, this is on stream.
It's fine.
What I still hear, what I still hear Kevin's dream.
I'm back.
I'm going in with less passion.
Because we're we can't.
No, you need a lot of passion.
Why did he took the left side?
Does he not?
Because we're away.
Oh, my God.
He already has everything he wants.
And now he's going to take the one.
thing I have left it's gonna take the one left side's fake
it's all right you don't need motion inputs to di just just
hit that oh my god wait you're right 20 yeah you plays Alex
oh god this is all I have left the left side oh my god nice
oh please okay maybe not nice not nice yeah the four you
know remember when he's oh my god coney please don't go easy
on me please just coney please no no no you guys weren't you
guys weren't supposed we don't we are taking that that's
what you're taking this is the one where i get to take it
off coney then we'll take it we'll take it we'll take it
that's a victory yeah i don't it counts it counts it
literally counts they've started it counts that's a really i
don't think so probably him to stop oh okay okay i see yeah
we're just gonna restart it so just just kill him yeah just
kill him yeah kill him quick okay i'll just throw lupin okay
now you know how he wants to you know how he wants to play
i'd already forgot i already forgot the opening what did he
do i don't even it was all a blur i think one thing uh
rushed you with something one thing it's alex you want to do
is if you see him going to have little stance you want a
neutral jump sometimes okay yeah because he might do the
stop and then you you land with a button and punish him or
he might do the elbow all right
okay I'm ready for some vibes gate based gameplay all right
am I allowed to play now no oh guys guys he saw me do what I
was gonna do he's downloaded me I'm so this is I think you
were about to win regardless this is a coughing baby versus
hydrogen bug event every time Tony and I were on the same
team he has always been one or two tiers higher than me yeah
I don't never be on the same level as him yeah I don't think
I don't think the tiers were
I don't think the tier is very balanced for you, or it's
honestly, I think.
There should have been an extra tier between Kony and Kyle.
There should have been an extra tier.
I agree.
And I think there should be a tier beneath me too.
Like there should just be like slaughtering fools in this
tournament too.
Yeah, but then those slaughtering fools would put in 80
hours and then they'll be diamond.
Yeah, that's true.
all right it's okay i got my one from coney that was all i
wanted doesn't matter how i got it it's still one yeah i
think i think the coughing baby about to show up this time
though i think i think the coughing baby about to put in
work fight 80 alexes in two weeks so i hope i land something
yeah i think i think you're good more popular than Chun-Li.
Alex is like, Alex just came out.
All right, just let me know when it's my turn.
They haven't said it yet, but it looks like they're about to
start coughing baby.
All right.
Locked in.
Okay, that's her new nickname?
Yeah.
Bullying live on stream.
Tune in.
You know what, whatever happens, guys, Yeah, you know, I'm
having a great time with you guys, you know, I'm very
passionate today And you know whoever wins is not going to
Japan exactly exactly all of us have went to Japan yes But
they will not yes, I didn't I didn't go to all of us have
went to Japan all of the ones that matter
Wait, I'm sorry wait To Japan Kyle
No, you can't take it back.
Yeah, you're destroying team chemistry right now.
We will take you to Japan one day.
Can I go or?
No, no.
You may not go.
That is crazy work.
You could have made me a hydrogen bomb, but you didn't.
I tried.
You could have made me a hydrogen bomb.
Bob I tried you're you're just nitrogen baby I I woke up at
7 a.m.
in Korea almost every day for you chide right what do you
mean bro I was I was there we we you guys can start you know
that I can start I'll make him wait I'm psyching him out all
right I mean, I went to Japan before, not for the event, but
I went.
Shut up.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
I can't focus now.
I can't focus.
It's not.
I can't.
Guys, someone saved me.
It's okay.
Someone.
You're good.
Okay, nice.
That was a good anti-er.
Yeah, and then he's...
No!
He jabbed me.
It's alright.
You know...
Oh, what?
Yeah, remember you want to try to neutral jump every now and
then, oh my.
Okay, well you are burnt out.
Nice.
Oh, I got some kick.
I got some jabs in.
I... I've never...
i'm okay i'm not okay i am not okay here i am like it's all
right that's i'm not okay here that's that's the one game
coughing baby coming through let's go come on you're good i
okay when just remember against alex you got a neutral jump
quite a bit because the command grab he's gonna do it a lot
yeah nice look i'm adapting yeah yeah remember my you can di
him you don't you don't respond to di's remember oh we got
one we got two guys i got him have hv i got him we think we
can get this round it's fine it doesn't even mean he's burnt
out he's throwing me i what i want keep holding up just keep
holding up when he's when he's in all you just keep holding
up he command grabs every time oh no i held up i held up i
swear to god no yeah yeah yeah when when when he's in that
stands don't jump at him okay yeah noise nice
nice i screamed because i was scared jump
wait no 10 you know what he might di a little bit more
against you because he knows you know i you know you know i
did do more damage than i thought i would do against coney
you could have run you could have actually gotten like two
rounds there yeah exactly exactly coughing baby had a knife
and stabbed him in the shins like the baby stabbed him in
the shins he didn't you know he couldn't walk for a day but
it's fine so he took a little bit of damage yeah i di
countered him is that that's all that matters no i was good
and it was a late one too so it looked like it was on
reaction yeah it was on reaction she doesn't she doesn't
sound very it was no it was on reaction uh maybe it might be
easier if you don't start up your uh your uh i'll just watch
through the spectator thing because um it wasn't that far
behind and i don't want your pc or your lag to yeah it's
it's pretty bad i'm not gonna lie yeah my horizon processor
is like cooking itself right now it's just it's jumping to
like 90 like randomly and it's okay because the more lag the
better it is good yeah we yeah we need we need that right
now we'll take the lag switch like yeah but like but it's
like all accident you know we're like what's going on and i
do know who what's wrong with like the internet guys not me
not me not my fault you got this okay i got it though no
problem you really guys they say you guys been starred by
the way oh guys i don't think i think you might never see me
another cap another new challengers guys next time they're
gonna put you higher
again they're gonna be let's clear i'm gonna be a master
just if i'm gonna be destroyed against hydrogen bombs oh
okay oh oh nice nice don't be afraid to just be higher in
the corner too okay scare a little bit yeah scare a little
bit gotcha
is that punishable no no no nice
it's okay guys i'm using the little punch for space a bit
more often also guys it's not because i don't want to be in
a new challenge i just don't think yeah i just don't think
i'm just a throw yeah play a little bit more loose get some
butt slams ahead of us i just feel bad because i'm obviously
not not supposed to be in this year i got you i need some
vibes based about
try to jab it so she doesn't walk forward and throw you yeah
a lot of people are just waiting for it and trying to walk
forward and throw you now so i'm like oh wait switch sides
yeah guys i'm just glad i did two weeks of practice because
it would look it would have looked a lot worse i try to jab
that but maybe it would have looked a lot worse nice
I don't know when Nice
No, it was an overhead Oh, no Yeah, I think I think the both
sides were Because I could I would have also Try and sit
there and parry I would have Yeah, I also just regular throw
I forgot everything about Honda Like do like Drive Rush,
Medium Punch or something And then like regular throw I
think that works Right Drive Punch, Medium Punch And a
regular Overcoming I just knew that The stuff I did Just
throw her some more was not gonna work in this year also
that's the thing so if she in case like you know you don't
get punished as much okay it was just not gonna work let me
give you like 30 seconds thinking that the lag is all i did
girl get back in there all i did was perform in here i was
doing like really cheesy because it worked against beginners
but like the people i'm playing Or am I sorry?
They're not really beginners.
Oh, I have to actually click it again.
I forgot.
I'm not watching on Discord anymore.
God, this skin is so distracting.
My Honda skin, I mean.
Yeah, the Honda skin is kind of crazy.
I know.
Oh, we're spectating already?
Oh, shit.
I forgot.
Yeah, I started.
Yeah.
okay i gotta get a little more silly with it nice yeah just
like that yeah especially if you think you sit here and
she's gonna throw a fireball like having a prediction on the
fireball and using butt sound is pretty good yeah yeah okay
yeah she why try to ah fuck you're right
see this could have been me this could have been me on honda
against bricky's chin lee that would but then you would only
see me spam three moves a little early I think you did a
little early okay
nice it's really neat but like a lot worse because I do not
know what I've seen I'm looking at moves I've never seen
before from from car cute
yeah a lot worse
yeah pressing the button he told me to press the You made it
work last time?
Yeah, because it was like beginner tier.
So, like, in that tier, all the cheesy stuff will work
because they didn't practice.
Yeah, it works against it.
Okay, okay.
I got to figure out a way to.
Yeah, I think, I think like when you use some stand medium
punch, too, it's good to throw in some butt slams and stuff
after that, after you do that, you know, because they're a
little bit less focused on dealing with it.
Yeah, sir.
All right.
Kyle.
All right, Kyle's time.
we just do an in-game in-game spectate uh if you can handle
screen sharing it probably would be better just so i can see
uh in real time and help you here it comes uh just don't
start just don't start yet so yeah yeah yeah all right here
we go
yeah they said they're recording these streams i hope
they're not like recording my perspective you know what i
mean i'm pretty sure they're recording every like individual
streams yeah of each of us because they have to get like
because if they look at like the others while you're playing
it'll be like dragon ball z yeah so i think they're gonna
swap but depending on who's playing at currently so it'll
probably be your perspective when you're playing and then um
oh no wait who even won against like who won the the alex
viper matchup was it the viper or or alex that one does
anyone know um it was the uh viper that one viper one though
yeah i know what the viper has like a thousand plus games so
yeah the viper one became a thousand plus games in two weeks
so that's understandable that's
the fight at the fight guys guys in the next custom after
the viper game i better see 20 tunlees a lot of advice
between these right i feel like i gotta go into the viper
gauntlet figure out yeah because this is just seating yeah i
mean i think the main takeaways is that you really just
gotta be ready to answer so we're gonna have to play again
uh just be mindful to the entire with the forward special.
So like basically like two fireballs and then the anti air
is my favorite.
So I wouldn't, I wouldn't put a number on the fireballs.
I would just say, like try to make it unpredictable.
Surprisingly, and Viper and Alex are not our DLC.
Don't, don't throw, don't, don't throw them like in patterns
like that.
Throw them when your opponent isn't expecting, like throw a
fireball and just wait and see what they do.
And if they're just not jumping at you, throw another one.
all right and then you know just yeah just just wait and see
sometimes you just want to not throw a fireball and wait for
them to jump too you know like is that it say to start
people just don't like free things all right we got this all
right and this is remember is it's three out of five you got
to win three times i believe i believe just don't get too
play like a we're about to We're sandbagging on purpose.
Is it actually just seating?
Yeah, it's seating.
No, in the top two.
Wait, oh, yeah.
Did they change them?
Nice, here you go.
Look, look, look.
Yeah, this is vibes-based.
Oh, just keep doing it.
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Oh, yeah, when you see that, you want to jump.
Yeah, when you see him put his arms up, just jump in it.
Oh, how do I hit?
Yeah, yeah, I'm sorry.
I was pressing the wrong button there.
Yeah, you're good.
I'll hit this.
Remember, yeah.
Nice.
some more fireballs maybe nice that's a combo oh wow so good
oh my god you're better than a gold player there you go so
good you're better than gold just just keep tossing those
fireballs if he gets close you john like if he runs at you
john this omics got nothing on you yep chuck them fire but
when he's full screen he can't he can't harm you so if he's
full screen chuck fireballs
Should not put him as a 20-pointer.
I like that.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
That's the thing.
In this eel, they don't play against the god.
Auto-heading.
And that's one day of sagat too.
Oh my god.
Imagine if you played sagat in the beginning.
imagine more fireballs firebar oh oh yeah punish it oh
punish it punish it yeah winnable let's go oh my god nice
guys this guy only had one day as to god because he tried to
play classic man or something remember to just fireball from
from full screen Oh.
Oh.
All right.
You're good.
Yeah.
You're burnt out here.
So just try to block a little bit.
Punch that.
Nice.
Anti.
Oh my god.
Try it back.
Yep.
Nice.
I wish I was in this tier.
This tier looks fun.
Fireball.
Yeah.
Yep.
Wait for the jump.
was yep oh nice drive oh wow sorry no you're fine that's
fine don't worry
i no longer belong there i missed this tier nice this here
would have been auto medium still after that this tier would
have been so fun i would have just practiced for one day
just to be fair you No.
Don't be afraid to DI a little bit more, too.
He's doing a lot of stuff that's very DI-able.
Yeah, there you go.
Nice.
That's coach.
That's coach right there.
Mm, there you go.
As close as you could just probably DI.
Oh, my God.
There he goes.
Oh.
He's going to hurt.
Oh, loyal fans.
No, I don't think that's modern.
No, it's going to be kill.
Okay, so what's the plan?
I'm waking up.
Do wake up, drive a reversal.
Oh, I don't think you can eat a DI.
Uh, DI, a DI.
Go ahead.
All right, never mind.
It went away.
I pressed the wrong button.
Hey, yeah, I don't think it would have mattered.
That would have beat the DI.
It's fine.
I think we should.
Yeah, yeah, it should have been neutral.
Yeah, neutral jump would have won that.
Yeah, neutral jump would have won.
Yeah.
I think we should try to play a little bit further away.
Like, you know, you don't want to get in too much.
Yeah, jump that.
Yeah, auto-heavy.
Nice.
Yeah, throw fireballs.
Yeah, from far away, fireballs.
Oh my god, he's so aggressive now.
Yeah, you also got a block on the block.
Just hold back a little bit.
Okay, that works.
That's okay.
Nice.
Good neutral.
Oh, he messed up too.
Okay, okay, okay.
I need to reset.
This guy's chasing me.
Yeah, he's trying to get you to the other corner.
He did.
Oh, don't talk.
I was panicking.
I was pressing all the wrong button.
I was at first damage.
Yeah, from one quarter to the next quarter.
No, I got him this time.
Yeah, there you go.
Nice.
That's how I used to the...
Yeah, see, that's all you gotta do.
Just DI him.
Fireball?
Nice.
They don't know how to counter DI.
They're like me because he don't know how to get forward.
He don't know how to move forward.
He's doing his best stuff out there.
It's crazy.
Yeah, exactly.
So we just have to wait.
No fireball.
Oh, perfect KO.
Let's go.
Nice.
Look at the suit.
Yeah, with the swoop.
With the suit.
Nice.
Could have been.
I wish I was in this tier, guys.
Oh no, he's panicking.
Good combo, bro.
How did I get burned out so fast?
Just eat.
Oh, it's because you, yeah, you blocked too much.
Got it.
Auto heavy.
Oh, I've got a lift.
Wow, that was unfortunate.
Bummer.
Alright, it's 1-1.
It's 1-1.
No, it's 2-1.
Oh, it's 2-1?
Oh my gosh, I lost track of the time.
God does remember your fireball the first game we were
winning yeah when he gets a little close you can wait and
not fireball let's see if him right here is okay nice nice
oh yeah remember your antires i wish i could die that much
but everybody just counters me just counter di's me so i get
scared of diying nice huge
i think if i di that coney would just piece my ass block
nice okay oh my god oh my god nice grab nice grab oh oh you
could you could punch them there when he I'm panicking, I'm
panicking.
He's tripping you.
You can punish that.
OK, we got it.
Nice.
OK.
All right.
That was great.
Yeah, that was the interesting round.
It's fine.
You were blocking.
That was good.
There we go.
Wow.
Auto heavy.
Huh.
nice nice uh i'm on modern that's just automatic i'm not
doing anything to get those yeah that is perfectly fine jump
jump jump jump yep didn't punish i'm sorry yeah that's fine
when you jump just make sure you try to auto heavy that
punish that dang that connects i think that that might kill
dude that's great no it's no it's modern you're fine so
what's a wake up you're alive but
Yeah, that's all right.
It's just a 50-50.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Okay.
That's funny to watch though.
Not gonna lie.
Like, what am I...
Yep, there you go.
Remember the anti-ers.
See, that's all we need to do.
It's just anti-er them.
Because he's gonna keep jumping.
Now we can probably throw out some DIs.
He's trying to get in.
Yeah.
walls could have grabbed him there he's gonna yeah he's
gonna jump soon there we go nice nice oh it's okay di maybe
yeah yeah yeah just just just do di just do di when he gets
close di yeah
Oh, he broke it.
Oh, no.
Oh, my.
That's close.
I had that I had that he really like, dang, you broke it.
Nice try.
You're actively improving so much as I fight with Guan.
You're adapting so well.
That's good.
We had it.
You had it.
It's fine.
You got better.
I think if he was doing that belly flop and I just did a
Shor Yuken, he dies.
If I just did a tiger uppercut.
Yeah.
that's hard yeah you just had to watch for the jumps a
little bit
all right feisty it's you now i see our carry just get us
10.
get us some points here yeah feisty well is that is that it
or no i can't tell i gotta play hodashi oh they still make
yeah oh yeah hodashi points for tiebreakers sake how are we
doing on points guys like 20.
yeah 20.
yeah but we're gonna get 30 soon we're gonna be 30.
we're gonna get 30.
what i mean smile oh god smile shine was playing he'd sweep
up a couple free ones for us too yeah shine can you like fly
over to want to replace right now and just yeah take the
controller i feel like it'd be a even matchup if you fight
the viper for me you think you think they notice i think
it'd be even yeah yeah we could do we could do par second i
don't know we could par second we could par second remote
remote services yeah we're just evening it up like yeah i
mean yeah i yeah i don't think anyone noticed i don't think
it's like is it like frustrating for you to watch that
sometimes when like you're you're kind of like on a whole
other level watching these matches is it like does it get to
you no not really i mean i i kind of like i i know the level
of play I kind of expect from like, you know what I mean?
Like it's not, I'm not expecting you to do some high level
technical stuff.
You know what I mean?
Like you're kind of just playing within the capabilities or
the time that you had to play.
So it's not, it's not really like that.
No, if you had like 2000 hours and you were like, you know
what I mean?
Like grand master, ultimate master ranked.
And I mean, you know, maybe I might be a bit more critical
of your, of your play.
He's very critical of me.
Yeah.
I watch, I watch him coach feisty and that, yeah, he'll,
that was on full list so critical because he knows what
you're capable of he knows yeah man all he wanted me to do
is throw like he didn't teach me a thing bro i did teach you
though i did teach you after our sessions you got you got no
no no stop it he's like he's literally like do you know what
you have to do and i'm like what he's like no all right
who's gonna No, no, no.
How much, how much, how much MR did you get before you left?
Bro, I don't want to hear it.
Yeah, but was it from shine or from others?
It was from my guidance, actually.
That's what some may say.
It was from my guidance.
Honestly, y'all can stay unmuted at this point.
I think we're playing for the vibes, to be honest.
I don't know if we can make to second or first.
I'm surprised we're not doing, um, we're not doing like
seating.
I thought we were going to do.
Well, he's 1500 MR.
I think I think they made it so that, um, I think they made
it so that, uh, it wouldn't be as long as last time.
Ah, I see.
Yeah.
I see.
Cause I heard, I heard you guys were playing until like 12
at night.
It was like four hours.
I'm pretty sure.
It was like four to five hours, maybe.
But also last time was like a lot harder.
Yeah.
So like everyone was like very even.
Nice bait.
I think there was just more teams in the last Challengers,
wasn't there?
No, it was still four teams.
It was still four teams, but like, I felt like last
Challengers, people were more even.
Like in tears.
Well, I think whatever tier you were in was more even for
you, for sure.
No, no, it was like every tier was like super close.
Well, I mean, I'm sure I'm just saying in comparison to now.
Yeah, yeah, 100%.
The place is a little, it's a little rough on you.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
It's not, it's not your...
At least Bricky and I, we had, like, we're, like, sort of on
the same wavelength.
Yeah, you and Bricky is fine.
But, like, yeah.
Kony was my tier in one of these events before when I played
against him.
It was my opponent once.
Yeah!
He was always two tiers above me when we were in the team
together.
How am I, Kony?
How am I the same as Kony?
Just two coughing babies.
I never played Super Smash Bros.
I should never, in my life, played Smash.
Yeah.
That's all right.
Oh, he missed.
He missed.
You're so much better.
Do it for the vibes.
I'm playing for the vibes.
Gaming for the vibes.
See, that's why he dropped that combo, because he got
something on the line, and I got nothing.
Exactly.
Have you ever played Street Fighter 6 with your good vibes
on the line?
I hope, I hope you don't make it to the finals, Cody.
I, I hope, I hope Feisty winning that doesn't lead you to
the finals.
I'm here to ruin someone's dreams.
Ruin their dream, Feisty.
Ruin their dream.
Cody lost the Viper.
So I know they have, they're like less dead points.
oh what the did it just kick me out of the uh ain't no way
they know they don't want you yeah if i didn't want you here
yeah i was just staring at the screen for a minute because
like i'm in it i'm watching it whatever i'm watching all
yeah also i think shine used to be in here when shine was in
here feisty was kicking ass true that's true get back in
here shy no i'm watching oh okay now i'm watching yeah we're
good
nice bait whoa
kyle watch the sagat do what he's doing do all of that but
like win see okay he is getting his ass but like Oh my god.
I'm here to ruin someone.
Oh, I missed.
Wait.
Oh, no.
I think you just delayed a little bit this one.
Oh, you might have jinxed it a little.
Oh, that was a good dodge.
That was pretty cool.
Oh.
Wow.
What?
Wait, does anyone know if...
Did JB's team won against the Viper team or lost?
Points-wise.
I don't know.
Yeah, I'm not sure.
Alright.
Oh, nice!
Punish!
God, I wish I could do stuff like that.
You could.
No.
Just no.
bro I just clocked your name I'm sorry it's because your
name three dollar right shine yeah holy shit my mind is
going back bro let's play like it's because he's playing
with money on the line we're not like what's going on bro I
want to know if they we could okay no that's sandbagging
What type of dastardly plan are you coming up with?
To guarantee something.
It's on jokes, guys.
It's on jokes.
I would never.
I'm just, I'm just messing about.
He said Holtashi's taking one minute, if that's okay, I'm
gonna say no.
if i see it and do it cpt rules i'm gonna i'm gonna time him
i'm gonna start timing him though one minute okay because
we're not toxic it's passion it's called it's called passion
you guys wouldn't understand it yeah it's passion we're not
mean people i not all of us anyway i personally think i bet
our team's the most fun right now the most fun to watch
they're all missing out you can't put a price on vibes yeah
exactly it's worth about three ray eyes three dollar i'll
change my name three cad
oh are they ready i'm spec dating yeah they're playing
already oh i didn't even realize nice nice
Oh no.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
Maybe he'll drop the combo.
Oh, he didn't drop it.
That's okay.
Oh my god.
Yeah, if he starts doing stuff like that, you can like
normal jump a little bit more instead.
He's just doing countering the elbow drop every time.
Yep, nice punish.
This is why he needed that minute.
Oh my god, bro.
Oh, what the lag?
Whoa!
End it.
What am I watching?
Nice, nice.
Cool optimal too.
Wow.
Like, you just did like 80 moves.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's not dead.
I'm dead.
Oh, you're dead.
We're good.
I'm gonna let her focus I'm not gonna talk now I'm like not
anxious or stressed anymore now that now that the oh my god
I dropped it lag switch nice now that I know all the
pressures got I'm chilling I'm having fun though I like this
team is all vibing I love hanging out with feisty we're on
the same wavelength we're both really toxic people it sucks
sorry just just block it out me and i'm dead you still got a
tiny bit of life left you can just block this out
i'm dead never mind yeah you actually are dead there's
actually nothing you can do about that situation wait was
there no way to fight back there was there was nothing you
Is it like a true block string or whatever you call it?
Yeah, it's just a string.
Yeah, and burnout.
And then he just de-is you and you're just dead.
So like, even if you block everything, you can't put any
like...
There was no way to...
That was...
You would have had to hold up.
Like, your best shot is to hold up and hope that you flip
out of, like, standing and punching a crouch, medium punch.
That was literally checkmate.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, it was one of those checkmates that you...
yeah there's no window to hold up and jump out or only if he
drops it i guess the best thing you could have done there is
if you if you did like crouch jab before he did uh the
forward heavy kick then you would have beat that but i
didn't think he was gonna do forward heavy kick there
actually well it's okay it's okay guys it's okay it's okay
because the vibes are on the line
on the last the last team we can literally do whatever we
want we can i mean i think yeah we could we could do
whatever we want i better see some vipers here i better get
into a vipers gauntlet all right so i mean who wants to go
first then i want to go second crickets i want to go doesn't
matter bro am i not going third i'll go wherever now you can
go third now i'm vibing out put me wherever carcass should
be last everyone should have a turn i'll go first then i'll
do that yeah do it kyle yeah there we go we got our order we
did shine's job for him okay so wait what do you mean by
that uh wait who's going first again oh it's kyle right yeah
bro wait so after I head button they block and they always
walk up and throw me am I you said I think who is it if I
see you said I'm allowed to jab in but before they get to me
or is there not yeah they're just walking to you like okay
like they're they're far away but you're letting them walk
up after that yeah because they know I'm holding my charge
so then I okay I gotcha yeah only if only He plays like
that.
I imagine that team would just be like just like they went
to a table and ate a bunch of ham sandwiches after their
win.
You know what I mean?
Why is ham sandwiches the only way?
You know, just like let's all get our little ham sandwiches.
We got our win, you know?
But why do they have to be ham sandwiches?
I'm confused.
Wait, is that how you, is that a normal celebration for you,
Kyle?
Like, no, that's like that to me, that's like the vibe of
their team of Team JB is like a ham sandwich team.
scene like my mom jb likes the only time i can watch it
who's mom though potashi's mom you think potashi's mom made
them some ham sandwiches is what i'm saying yeah okay i see
that i can see that all right here we go
and i don't mean it in a rude way they just seem like a ham
sandwich kind of team like so what are we bb and jay so what
are we like you know like we're like we're like like one of
those like fancy like uh really like um you know like uh i
don't know like modern type of you know like those fancy are
like sandwich restaurants you know with like really crispy
bread yeah the business is going out of in a really trendy
neighborhood we're going out of business we're never gonna
see each other again after this
that's right i'm angry i'm gonna beat all of you up that's
right daddy's angry
daddy's angry get in here we're a beef patty team we could
be beef patties
meetings at a bad day at work oh i see yeah i could go for
some beef patties then abuse goblin time beef patty on a
burger it's abuse goblin time like jamaican patties i like
jamaican patties they're good
right uh so if i'm up against the my do i change do we like
i mean do i change strategy at all it seems like you know
just remember to do fireballs is so hard for me because like
the second they beat it i i drop it immediately you know
what i'm saying um i mean it would depend like if they're
really throwing like she's gonna be throwing fireballs at
you too so that's me um but your fireballs will beat her
normal fireballs so you can still throw fireballs until she
chucks a metered a powered up one yeah when you're playing
cigar how much you do the fast fireball and how much do you
the normal one it depends on the situation I tend to do the
fast one a lot more no anything let me choose a medium one
every now and then because I think about how you said you
could walk up behind the medium fireball I've never done
that in my life yeah I i think i think for you i wouldn't i
wouldn't overthink it i think just think just just stick to
the heavy fireball for now that's right get out yeah heavy
fireball maybe the low fireball or something but just
between those two i'm coney now you're me
this is how i fell against coney not so great is it not so
great
Shaina, I want you to know that I'm beating up a 1900 Sagat
right now.
See, so like, what do you think the difference is?
I think the difference is that I had no will to play because
my entire team lost.
I mean, that's fair.
But how are the vibes, though?
The vibes are amazing.
I'm having a great time.
Are you actually having a great time?
you just saying that i'm having a great time is that a pr
response is that a pr response also like the difference is
that the sagat you first had the one minute timeout time
yeah yeah that one minute that meant one minute meant
everything we should have timeouts you think we need
timeouts yeah i think so why didn't you ask for a timeout
for us We needed the mental reset.
I mean, you know, I guess you could, I mean, I guess you
could choose that one minute.
The CPT rules.
CPT rules.
There was a break after he won, too.
That's true.
He got to win.
And so I need 60 seconds after that win.
It's like, it's like FIFA.
We gotta, we gotta fake an injury.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Are you locking in over there feisty?
I'm dead.
Oh, the, the, the, wait, the 1900 MR?
I mean, it's 1-1 right now, but he just invited me to a
deposit room, so I'm just gonna quit because it's the guy.
I think it's fun when you talk about MRs and like power
levels.
That's right!
I'm angry!
Yeah, I mean, after you reach master, that's like, oh,
there's like a whole system.
guys i'm sorry i'll beat you guys up another day kind of you
know it's it's your ranking i'm sorry guys go back into the
abuse basement i'll come back for you guys later we are home
so we get left side so doki hear that i'm so i'm so happy i
can't believe they gave coney left side like did he really
need that side
all right i'm having a great time i'm having a good time too
guys is there a sarcasm in there no i'm actually having a
great time me too like imagine if like like you know no
pressure the people were like mean and frustrated you know
what i mean that would like that's what i'm saying yeah if
we're actually like the vibes a lot here if we're all losing
together we are more bonded as a team for all i mean i'm not
losing together we're all losing together it's called team
shine your name boot up a rank game right now let me see you
get whooped yes shine boot up a rank game right now just so
you guys can see me lose yes so you can be part of the team
are you not part of what kind of captain are you not even
standing united with your players have to lose with you yes
i see hmm it's called benmon is playing alex i wish her the
best because i have nothing to lose do you have time can i
boot up a ranked game or how much time no well well you're
last so yeah yeah i gotta support the team your last so you
you could technically it's okay don't worry the vibes are
immaculate don't worry we'll give you a live commentary and
what's going on yeah um i gotta give some lore on the abby
cakes matchup so i was just playing late one night and i
actually like randomly went up against her and she was my
and this was when i was you know i was just trying to do
monone and she kept throwing fans at me and killed me you
know just destroyed me four zero now we're gonna throw some
yeah and you're gonna throw back she forced my i will say
you have a lot of confidence to do classic in the beginner i
think it's more fun more fun to just like tap things out and
have six buttons of punches and kicks you know i think it's
like more fun a little bit i think like with two weeks
though it's a lot to take in yeah it is
oh my god here we go i'm glad i mean it would have been cool
we had seating as well but then we finished early too so you
know i can't complain i get to go out early all
right so shine question how she will start the match is
taking two steps backwards and then throwing a fan yeah what
like if i'm like 90 sure that's what she'll do what should i
do um i mean you can just jump forward you can just walk
forward a little bit and jump forward when you like if you
if you really think she's gonna like throw the fan you just
jump forward over the fan and then get a huge punish if you
are unsure then you can just back up and throw a fireball
whatever but yeah you can make a hard call out and like or
or you can walk forward in di as well too but you have to do
that early enough yeah i always mess that up and honestly
like nothing embarrasses me more than doing a drive impact
out in the field and then i wish like i thought break you
feel so like as in like i mean you do but i mean like you
just gotta throw them out sometimes it's gonna happen that's
like my second or third game because then i would have been
much more warmed up of using di's i mean sometimes you just
have to use them except that they might they might get
countered it would have been like at least i would have like
got that out of the way
so i could have got i think i i was so close to beating that
too to beating him which one i can't see you oh yeah like
that is that what is that what is that what is that i do
like yeah yeah it's nice it's making me a little bit
uncomfortable why i don't know his face has a little bit too
much detail you should pull one pull one in the chat what's
your favorite one what about this one oh i know that i know
that that manga i've seen that i read that before i remember
where he's from which one's what i got here
damn i have a lot more than i thought why yeah you're not
posting any why is yeah i'm looking
here isn't he supposed to be i don't know bro i don't know
go with your team bro are we in the right place i don't even
know anymore yeah we are because abby cakes yeah they
invited us here he's larping right now he's larping he's
scouting out his he's scouting out his opponents
you like this one i like that one what is he holding it's a
butter it's a piece of butter yeah no it's like those things
you put they put on sushi but i don't know what it is the
egg oh is it tomago oh because it's all because it's a sushi
yeah they have like sushi one yeah it's like this one that's
how i feel in my tier look at this one oh i like that one
that's from a that's from battle network i love battle
network that's from the anime too
an anime oh yeah i mean yeah about yeah it does have an
anime yeah i just played i just played the games yeah i like
that one actually where'd you get that one i don't know she
just got no you guys you guys are sorry in the end we we're
gonna get a free battle pass too true no true you know what
we get a free battle pass shine okay why do you bring on me
shine was like
whoa whoa what an exaggeration exaggeration what wait what
did he say i'm not surprised but what did he say yeah so
they said they said do you guys need any battle passes and i
was like is this open for the newest one and he was like no
unfortunately and then shine just had to chime in and be
like i see of course she's trying to scam again yeah and
then we got tifa oh yeah never hurts to ask always shoot
what i said yeah always shoot your shot thank you okay but
you are always trying to scam though like that's not that's
not scamming we're just asking if we could yeah potentially
because we are so passionate about the game you see if i see
them doing the same wavelength that's what i'm saying yeah
we went to universal together yeah we did yeah it was crazy
yeah and then there were so many lines did you know if i I
found out when we were there, it was like at 90% capacity
when we were there.
Dude, yeah, no, I went there.
When I went there with my mom after, it was raining, so it
was actually like no one.
Did you even do the rise?
I couldn't.
It was raining.
I did like the ones that we could, like not the outside
ones, you know?
Yeah, we bonded with lions.
Yes.
You guys really keep talking about your trip to Japan.
Yeah.
A lot.
It was great.
Yeah, you know, Karku, what did you do in Japan when you won
your tournament?
Oh, you know, combinis and a little late night, a little
late night skewers.
I had a lot of meat.
That was so much meat.
Oh, yeah.
Too bad Sean would never get to experience that.
You know what else we did?
We went to the muscle mommy bar.
Oh, yeah, we went there too.
You do know I've been in Japan like three times, right?
Yeah, but you didn't do it.
didn't get it for free like us but every time i went well
the two times i went it was for free though but you didn't
get get it paid by capcom like us one of them was paid by
capcom what are you talking about we need some some some
fireballs fireballs oh wait we're playing okay sorry just
yeah di or i did get slapped like justin that's the crazy
part all right oh punish that yeah oh that works that works
what is going on my god nice oh look at us you know what cow
you gotta apply again for new challenger so you're put in
the same tier and then you get to go to japan i really i
feel i feel like this is just you know my origin yeah don't
worry they'll put you in the same tier because as long as
you don't rank up Stay in this yellow and then you get to go
to Japan And then make sure side doesn't draft you nice nice
nice, you know, oh, I failed.
I shouldn't have failed.
It's okay It's okay.
It's okay.
You're doing it
Oh, I like that.
Oh, it's oh you hit your first counter di Nice, nice, we
love that.
Oh, yes, we love to see that Now we should fireball some
more, probably.
Oops, my bad.
Let's do a low one, do a low one, yeah.
Mix it up, mix it up, yeah.
Yeah, we can do this all day.
We can do this all day.
Exactly.
There you go.
Oh, wait, maybe she can do it all day.
It's okay.
She's worked out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're fine.
Nice.
Throw some...
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh!
That was close.
Okay, we were doing good.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Yeah!
Nice!
I wish I could do that.
Nice.
But you can.
No, I can't.
They're just gonna counter DI me.
Nice!
Oh my god, look at you.
She doesn't know how to counter DI.
Oh, but she knows how to grab.
Yep, remember.
Some fireballs?
Yeah, yeah, more fireballs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just chuck them, chuck them.
Yeah, yeah, we're back in business.
Yeah, she can't do this all day.
Just remember that.
She's almost burned out.
She's almost burning herself out.
Yes, just keep doing it.
Just keep doing it now.
Oh.
It's okay.
Nice.
Nice!
Oh!
Knee!
There you go!
You got a round!
That's one round!
Run round!
After this tournament, do not rank up so you can go to
Japan.
How do you know the next one to Japan?
It could be like...
Eventually one of them will be in Japan.
Back to Orlando.
Florida!
Whoa!
Hey, man.
Oh, I think I'm second.
No, I'm second.
Yeah, he's here.
Oh, it was close.
Yep, she didn't react.
It was just pure reflex.
Oh, she's doing the throw loop.
Oh, I missed it.
Oh.
Remember, you can drive reversal.
Remember, you can wake up drive reversal that.
Nice.
Get out of there.
Oh.
Oh, you're burned out.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Yeah.
When she's throwing you in the corner now, I remember you
can wake up drive reversal, you know.
DB.
Yes, he does.
He knows.
I feel like we could be doing some QBs.
That would work too in that situation.
Nice.
Fireballs.
Oh, she counted.
Yeah, be careful.
Be careful.
You might be doing a little bit.
Oh, she messed up.
That's okay.
She messed up her combo.
She messed up the combo.
Oh.
Nice.
Just keep doing that.
Yes.
Just keep doing it.
She can't.
Yes.
Just keep firebugs.
Yeah.
Down, down, down, down, down, down, low, low, low.
Just keep doing it.
We'll take it.
Get, oh.
Nice!
What?
Oh, oh, oh, that's fine.
That's actually not even that bad.
Yeah, that's great.
More fireballs, more fireballs?
More fireballs, more fireballs.
Wow.
They call up on her board.
Emma.
Damn.
Yeah, yeah, be careful how much you're doing.
She's counter GI now.
Yeah.
I could how come I I can't grasp counter di's oh how did
that kill it was a powered up version yeah because she had
her stock to me oh okay we need to just fireball more and
wait for her to jump then we can dp yeah yeah yeah oh
she's doing the combos oh nice nice that was actually nice
on nice we like that nice yeah oh she's trying to di you now
too yeah she's doing dis now you can you can freely di a
little bit here though because she's in burnout all right
wake up dp
oh she's adapting nice
oh oh she's gonna get closer to you though yeah just be
careful using that burn out a lot.
Sorry, you got around.
You got around.
We got one around.
Yeah, we did good.
Yeah, we were going crazy.
You had one day off the guy.
So, like, you did really good.
The worst part about losing a street fighter is, like, you
were too basic.
You know what I mean?
Like, you lose because your opponent was, like, more
creative than you are.
You know what I mean?
That's what hurts the most for sure.
They just know a little bit more moves.
They mix up a little bit more.
yeah that was perfectly winnable though yeah just remember
that's what's sad about it yeah we had that yeah just
remember you had one day on sagat and you almost you almost
pulled it out she's been on my for two weeks who are you on
before sagat oh you're playing monon monon yeah classic
monon too classic monon my god i was that's why i was like
he was very brave for trying
I'm second, right?
I already forgot the order.
You are second, yes.
Okay, all right.
Here we go.
I hope after this tournament, I will meet all of you guys
again.
See you in the next challenger.
Street Fighter Challenger, slams, whatever.
I think the only way I can do the next challenge is I
actually get the diamond.
I think...
I don't think I could pull off another plot, another plot
hour.
I mean, they might, again, they might put you in Feisty's
tier.
Oh, that's, oh, true.
They slowly upgrade me each tier, every tournament.
Yeah.
I can never catch up.
I'll apply for next one, just to see, just to see if they
still want me after everything.
All right.
and mashing they always need a foil
maybe after I swear to god if my gets nerfed after if my
gets nerfed after like for the next challenger and I get in
I swear to you guys I have to learn another new character in
two weeks I swear to god I hello this is it this is it
points points on the board this is wait wait that's not it
big city ricky
oh hello whoa default skin let's go nice noise oh that was
sick oh couldn't react to that what yeah that's gonna throw
you a curveball when you try to antire but it's fine
Look at that.
I'm burning out.
Okay.
You're both burnt.
But you're a fire-based character, so I think you would not.
You're in your element.
That's true.
Hold on.
Hold up.
I'm cooking here.
That's true.
Check another one.
I got it.
Oh, we got it.
Go for it.
Let's go.
I got it.
I didn't get that on Cody, though.
in oh my god okay to jump in on him here
i'm burnt out oh it's okay this is good he's gonna be burnt
out soon oh fuck
no it's all right are you good i got around though you're
cooking cooking you're cooking
nice oh
I messed up there.
It's okay.
Nice blocks, though.
Oh, oh, oh my God.
That was so good.
Hold on.
Can't here.
He can't here.
Okay.
It's okay.
You're getting your meter back.
Nice, nice.
Oh, he blocked it.
I thought he was going to...
What is that?
I thought he was going to jump.
You're still in the health lead, Joanne.
Am I still alive?
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
No.
Did I get this?
Yes!
You got it!
Watch my cuisine!
You lost to me and I'm a baby plat!
You too!
They're coughing baby in these business.
Imagine dying to a plat!
She's toxic.
Nice.
Mm.
Ooh.
I like that.
Throw loops.
Pump on him.
He can't eat.
He can't eat here.
Nice.
Okay.
You don't need your meter.
It's fake.
Cross.
She is moving.
She's moving.
Boy, she's moving.
Oh.
Very nice.
Yes!
Yo, check the PC.
Are you on parsec?
What's going on?
Guys, parsec's on!
Parsec's on!
Oh my god, parsec's off, parsec's off!
Parsec's off now!
Bro, she's doing dry rush, Oki.
I didn't...
It was Mickey, bro.
The Mickey training.
Oh, come on.
Don't say that.
Yeah, shine!
Why didn't you teach me this what do you mean i thought i
taught you a lot of this what are you talking about
nice nice punish oh my god why are you killing him like this
coughing baby stand up oh god oh god stop you're giving me
too much confidence yes yes coughing baby stand up my one
big city ricky send him back to a rural suburban village
what is no wonder you were put in this tier what's that
thousand matches for huh i took half your matches and i beat
you i oh my god she's locked in no i'm sorry i'm i'm
passionate i'm passionate i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm beat up my
dragoons during customs here so it worked look i mean ricky
bconi i beat ricky i'm the tier in my tier.
True.
There's nobody more dangerous than a tier.
Never underestimate the coughing baby.
That was sick.
Was that online?
Was that online or offline?
I'm gonna pee roping.
Was that on stream?
It was off stream.
No!
That should have been on stream.
stream
that was sick though coney could never you were moving real
comfortably i know that's what i meant i should have had you
shouldn't have given me bricky at last if you put me at
second we could have had it i mean possibly yeah i don't
know you think so i don't know you think he didn't try to
die you though yeah but i had too much pressure this was me
playing with the vibes when the pressure's off it just
unlocks exactly i unlocked like a third eye there but no
pressure you like when there's no pressure you don't counter
di though it wasn't even close ricky it wasn't even close
that was a solid two oh
practically a diamond player now oh I just needed to be more
mad I guess I think that's it all right I'm going get in
there all right I believe sign what did you tell me against
Alex if you're in like stay about mid-range where slide will
hit yes do slide I did it's pretty good for stopping him
from just doing slide randomly i'm sorry doing prowler
stance randomly okay if he if he is in prowler stance you
use crouch heavy punch to beat the stomp but just remember
just the easy way is just a neutral jump every now and then
if you see him in prowler stance oh my god who is that the
viper was the one i had the most success on the viper was
the one the hardest the strongest player was able to win but
I remembered it when it mattered exactly
they couldn't predict me look at that okay so the thing is
you don't want to do it when he's already been in prowler
stance just just just start neutral jumping if you like or
try to neutral jump and read the stomp if you see him
already in it but if he's just activating it like you want
to react to it and then do prowler crouch the slide sorry i
don't even know what this character does but i've never seen
that in my life this is like little sweep option he does two
kicks here see this is why i had to fight 20 80
alex's yeah i had to i had to beat up the dragoons i'm thank
you dragoons no no this is good but you're getting your
drive gauge back oh that was a good call that was good i
think i should i should have definitely just practiced chun
li Before the first match, I was like, let's just do
everything.
Because I legitimately forgot all of Chun-Li's movesets.
Nice.
There you go.
I forgot all of Chun-Li's moveset when we had to fight.
Because I only fought one Chun-Li.
Out of 80 Alex's and five Vipers.
You know what?
We finish it off strong.
respect to the fallen dragoons that let me beat them up yeah
you want to try a neutral jump when you think she might do
the stop out of probably stance yeah
oh yes oh it worked out
it was so winnable it's just the first like i said it was
like last match it was last match i don't really know what
to do like last game and also i didn't warm up in I mean,
don't be afraid to just drive rush at him either, you know,
like if you're not, if you're not sure he's not really
Like I just don't know when to jump I did level one there
Look guys all those hours I think I think I played like I
played I played like 500 plus games guys All those late
night hours grinding rank bashing my head against the wall
learning my from scratch in two weeks reinstalling street
fighter six two weeks ago after a year you kind of have to
just yeah like stuff like that like you if you see her going
to prowler stance it was all worth it oh we might not be in
the finals but she's doing the stomp but she's doing the
like immediately after she goes into vs sands so if you see
probabilist and just try to neutral jump every now and then
there you go nice nice it paid off i'm gonna spend it
because i just don't even know i don't know it's all right
you'll have the buff for next round but yeah she's doing an
option in probably stance immediately after so every now and
then just neutral jump and then you know I don't even know
when I'm new, I don't know.
I don't know.
No, that's what I'm saying.
When you see progress, then, because she's doing the action
right after she enters.
Professionals.
She's doing the stop after she's like, right after she
enters.
Maybe I am the prodigy.
Oh, no.
I went in with like, I'm just going to be the coughing baby
and hope for the best.
I had it so big now.
It is.
I'm riding that high.
It's time to hop for a deer now.
Oh nice.
You did?
Yeah you did.
Okay, it was a good game though.
Wait, is this a 20 pointer?
Oh wait, it's a 20 pointer.
Big comeback.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come back, come back.
It's like the finals.
What?
Yeah, you see when she wins.
she goes into power stance you got a neutral jump well
yeah i don't know how to fight alex i got no clothes i got
no clothes sorry no that was the last game we're just we're
just here to be supportive i'm riding my high oh
yeah i'm not playing more that was the last one that's why
i'm riding my high right now i'm here to be moral support
for my team
okay nice feisty nice she's fighting back yeah i'm trying
i'm not a fighter i told you nah she's a fighter she's a
fighter i believe feisty come on
guys imagine that one year my imagine that one year my i
could i could take just imagine guys i'm not a fighter
imagine yeah if anything if you see the stomp at least kind
of like perfect area or something too no
i would oh i mean you're not dead but but i'm dead you are
empty
that was ggs i got no clue what alex do bro i don't know i
just don't know yeah like so the thing is like they can
delay when they do stomp but specifically when every time
she entered prowler stand she always did this the stomp
immediately so that's what i'm saying once you see it you
can neutral jump and you'd probably get a punish there all
right we saved the best for last the best we saved the best
for last last match yeah that's it feisty we have the same
record yeah i think we have we have the same record we're
like the same wait practically if i win are we going to the
finals hell no i don't even think if i won we would go to
the finals
we are we are we i think this could be like one of either
this team or coney's team is getting kicked out of the
finals so it depends on if I think us in this team are not
going to the finals I think it's only the other team.
Wait is there a record?
Where's the score for it?
No but then the thing is I know they don't post it.
I know like I know like Viper the Viper won against Kony so
you're technically up there.
Yeah but I think when we had 20 points they had 30 points
but the other teams i don't know i don't know i got no clue
i might we wait me winning this game might have kicked them
out of the finals oh we're playing spoilers oh my god we
denying people trips to orlando i can't i wonder if i denied
them of the finals when i you were not going to disney would
i make you feel better you gotta gatekeep if you win you
definitely gatekeep this team all right i'm in you got this
can't start yet right oh no they haven't said anything oh
yeah they haven't said it yet the finals gatekeeper we have
nothing to lose we actually i don't we have nothing we have
nothing to lose for the past like few games we could lose
the vibes though yeah we would never lose the vibes we would
never lose the vibes
damn so is the secret who goes to the finals basically like
you can do the calculations if someone was watching the
stream and calculating this point oh my chat oh i see it
yeah no no no there is no chance for this there's no chance
yeah jb team got 80 nephew team got 60 duo kevin team which
is this team got 40.
so even if they win here they will not be in the finals
matter of fact man we're the we're not the only one
struggling today no it's because i i think i it's because i
it is it is yeah yeah actually yeah you did actually i i
gave you literally gave him you did she was way too happy
about that what if what if it was someone's dream to go to
orlando ready let's go you're not going that way i don't
know hold on all right they didn't update the points for
this last one oh yeah maybe they just got 20 yeah they
probably just got yeah that's true wait but then they did
update they did get 20 but i know but then the other team my
my yeah i don't know i don't know i don't know if they
updated that well if you and karku and then it would have
been a solid gatekeep that's true dad yeah karku you gotta
do this for me man you got i don't know why i'm diying he's
got the reactions oh my brain is off my bad my bad my bad
the perfect parry was really cool by the way that was sweet
yeah i missed out on it i was too busy being a gatekeeper
toxic no a gatekeeper it's passion i got counter hit i'm
hitting i'm hitting too many buttons my dead no you're not
dead he could have killed you but you're not dead oh my god
i'm just gonna wake up level three but yeah yeah honestly i
would have done this at that point just let her rip yeah
yeah okay please for the i'm about to get cheesy with it
let's go i believe i believe oh he knows it's fine don't let
that discourage you let it ride let it ride karku okay nice
oh oh yeah she's plus on that why's that reach so far uh
just a pretty long button cammy buttons pretty good
oh my gosh yeah it's already so alive oh okay oh
yeah you gotta be careful okay okay okay okay it's okay it's
warm up remember remember after you do medium punches then
you can start throwing in some butt slams so they're not
going to be looking for
because this is why i didn't keep learning honda
oh my god i had to ah the counter hit
nice oh yep he's moving he's moving very nice come back i
don't want to waste level three oh it doesn't kill sorry
we're good nice nice nice and he held on to the meter yeah i
i i wasn't sure about the kill so i just uh that was
oh nice oh i should chop there
oh my god i'm getting counter i'm just i'm i got rolled no
it's all right my bad guy it's okay it's okay no it's okay
we'll see how it goes half a round yeah that's fine guys we
did our best we did amazing we did our best we did our we if
if they added seating we would have been in the finals
that's all i'm we would have we would have robin we could
have adapted yeah if it was round robin we would have been
in the finals exactly we actually we would have scouted we
would have figured out game They knew.
No.
They knew.
Ricky is still scared of you.
That's right, Ricky.
Better sleep with one eye open, Ricky.
I'm gonna find out where you live.
No, I won't find out.
That's a joke.
That's...
I'm just trying to flip that part.
They had to nerf us, guys.
Like, I'm warmed up now after that.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
I would have.
I didn't have enough time.
I just needed the warmup.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Well, you know what, wait, should we, I wonder, should we
check out like who makes it to the finals before we go?
Yeah, it's not us for sure.
I'm sure.
But we want to know who makes it though, don't we?
Yeah, yeah, I do.
We got it.
We got to know, even if I did beat Bricky, I don't think we
would have made it into the finals.
I don't, I don't, I don't think so.
I think we probably need to.
I don't really know what they were doing.
Did I already play?
Like...
Oh.
I don't know.
Are they...
Are they still playing?
Are they streaming right now?
I don't know.
Where's the stream?
Actually...
Where's new challenges?
I'm pulling up Koenig's stream.
I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know either.
Wait, Koenig's not even watching.
Wait, I think they're done.
I think they're waiting, too.
They're waiting for the score calculations.
But I'm going to...
they're looking at our match so does that mean they already
played so what's wait i think maybe maybe duo kevin team did
get second then maybe maybe if that was the updated
scoreboard for the two teams but not for our two teams then
yeah maybe they're updating it as the as the main thing goes
on like as a mainstream goes on you know yeah maybe oh
they're watching it now oh my god
not gonna expect this
oh so i guess after this then then the swap over this is so
i guess they're always like behind it wait are they watching
the replay yeah they're watching the replay oh okay so it's
just like they're gonna be watching your pov yeah i wonder
if it's like the full the full match or just like the
highlights oh my god wait justin's gonna watch the fireball
spam and then oh no i bet justin i oh wait what would justin
say oh wait yeah it's just uh highlights wait so who got
second then oh you think we did
something like that man
oh they're just doing like highlights of it yeah well yeah
it's because we were off stream so they have to watch this
and then they'll show but like boy that's some fast editing
it's like fading out into the hotspots whoa you're right
somebody on their team's working really hard on this yeah I
mean they are a production company they're pretty fast about
this bro you don't see like I see my opponent Abby cakes and
like I see her like she's just smarter than I am you know I
think she's had more time on the character I think if you
had if you had more time on also my is like the best
character in the game right now so yeah like she's really
she's just fireball fireball fireball that's
it hmm all right well yeah I don't know let me see how I
find it green in the corner wait i don't think they got it
because because justin just said that duo kevin needs the 50
bomb so did they lose them because of dokey did she actually
dokey i think so i think so why is she laughing so hard
about that i'm just i'm proud of myself you know i'm i'm
proud i'm just proud of myself that no one no one believed
in I didn't believe that was from a photo shoot actually
that fit that picture but it was from like a it was one for
like a blood tree fire leaves we did well I don't know where
his is from but mine was from that
that's like a win in my book my goal was to my goal was to
take get one win yeah I feel like someone's day I feel like
you gatekeeping someone like I don't think you would have
been this happy if you qualified I would be I I would be,
because I would not have expected it.
I don't know.
I just feel like you gatekeeping someone is actually giving
you more joy than if you would just, like, qualify for the
finals, actually.
This seems to be a very enjoyable experience for you.
Wait, I'm watching my highlights right now.
Yeah, they're showing your highlights now.
She's not trying to listen to me at all right now.
Wait, I think maybe it's tied.
I don't know.
damn now you're actually huh if it's tied then she's
actually inconveniencing the T.O.s and the tournament too
all in one go wow that first one was so sweet oh my god yo
donkey your vtuber is so cute oh thank you that's how I feel
right now playing this game sleepy
wait wait I wait I broke his win streak oh did he not lose
yet yeah I guess he didn't lose yeah yeah because he beat
Bricky and he beat uh yeah he probably had yeah he had no
idea what was coming to him I literally don't know oh yeah
no no you did sealed the deal.
I sealed the deal.
You know what he said?
They needed a 50 pointer.
Wow.
They are distraught about not going to Orlando right now.
How do you feel about that?
You know, I feel so bad.
You know, everyone deserves a chance to go to Orlando.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm in Orlando right now.
Everyone deserves a chance to go to Disneyland.
It's unfortunate that, you know, i agree it's it's
unfortunate and it was unfortunate that i had to be the one
that gate kept them and i really do feel for them see that's
passion that is passion that's passion right there yeah dude
they won by 10 points bro oh my god oh my god we have minus
I gotta throw that in chat.
It's so funny.
Oh my god.
This battle differential is crazy.
That's tough.
Damn, close one.
Damn, I think it was pretty close.
Oh my god.
I think it was pretty close though.
Hey, it could have been minus 27.
Just remember.
It could have been worse because I got four rounds off.
Oh my god.
Okay, it could have been a lot worse.
It could have been minus 30 if you think about it.
Oh, yeah.
If I won that fight against Bricky, it would have not done
anything.
I mean, it would have, we still needed 40 more points.
We still needed 40 more.
Damn, bro.
It literally just, it just completely wouldn't have mattered
at all.
Like, though, that last, actually, well, it would have
mattered because for us to stop them.
But for us, we just wanted to stop someone.
That was just it for us.
It's all right, guys.
We're all winners here tonight.
Wait, we should watch Shine lose a, boot up a ranking right
now, Shine.
Boot up a ranking right now.
Let us watch.
You really want that?
Yes.
Give us a, yes.
We will all watch you play rank.
Okay, all right, sure.
Do I have to stream it on Discord too?
Like, oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
All right, I see.
All right, man.
I love it.
It's your trade.
This is my trip to Orlando.
I can't play Honda.
But if I play Honda, I'll definitely win though.
You should play, like, each of our characters.
Play my.
You should play each of our characters.
My Honda, Kim, and Sagat?
Yeah.
And then, so we can see how it's done, you know?
but what if i win what if i win all four uh shine look at
our team bro look at our team bro shine i feel like i win
all four bro do you think we're come on man i i feel like
look at our team but i can be the one that wins though no
yeah oh sure buddy what do you what do you mean by that all
right sure you can what what character am i playing first
then which one you not kimberly that's too easy no wait no
play sagad play sagad we go straight up we go by tears oh go
by tears yes yeah yeah that's one that's cool that's the god
first wait that's actually a easy one for him also wait oh
wait it's fine just watch all of it all right give us give
us some play by educational commentary okay yeah yeah oh an
ed smash was kind of kind of hard oh and you have to play
modern for mine you know oh you play this character bro you
got 400k points or lp yeah all right we're watching
he's trying yeah i'm watching i am i am i am wow he does not
want to you're breaking his one one and done him too one and
done him
Oh, no, he's fighting back.
He's fighting back.
How tall is the guy?
Why is legs so long?
I feel like you kicked him across the map.
The guy is so hard to predict because he's so big.
That's what I'm saying.
His arms go hella far.
Yeah, I don't know if he's low or medium because he's so
big.
I mean, I could curse now.
I was going to say he's so fucking big.
Fight back, Ed.
Fight back.
Oh.
you won't wake up db oh no no no no no no oh i told you he's
playing like his life is on the line right now this is his
orlando trip this is his orlando trip guys if you want to
watch the fight is on shine stream oh no i'm being
distracted right now that's right we're cheering for ed i i
know my whole team is cheering against you which is crazy
but i always come in the clutch dad in his veins or what i
do all right i'm chilled right now so you're gonna win and
done him are you gonna want to done him i don't i don't want
to do that one and done him one and done him one and done
him one and done watch him request match watch him request
match and then quit he did it already oh quit quit yeah
leave it quit just leave you guys are evil come on You know,
Shine wanted to run it back because he got a plus 10.
He wanted that yellow so badly.
All right, what's the next character?
Modern my.
No, it can't be modern.
No, I'm going to lose her modern 100%.
I'll play.
You're scared.
I'll play him.
I'll play him my.
Why are you so scared?
Shine.
What do you mean?
This is fair.
You just want to see me lose.
Like how it wasn't fair for me when I got my ass the other
way.
Clearly it was fair.
You beat the best player in your tier.
It wasn't fair from the start.
No, you beat the best player in your tier.
I had to invest at least 50 plus hours of Street Fighter to
get to that level.
Okay, but look at my buy though.
Oh my God.
Okay.
looking i'm looking hold on looking more fans more fans shy
we need more fans thanks coach remember the throw loop oh
that sounds familiar oh my god remember to counter di
where's this is what you wanted you wanted i hope he i hope
she di's you why do you want that so bad
Come on, DI her.
DI her.
Oh, damn.
Maybe I was parseced.
That wasn't optimal.
I forgot the combo.
She just needs to hit you once.
She won't hit me once.
You don't think so?
No.
Oh.
Wow.
You're so random.
This guy.
Oh.
Can't wait to see Shindling Honda.
Yes, please.
Yes.
Come on.
Doki, you see it?
Yeah, I know.
There's the DI.
Doki, you see it?
How come you never taught me how to counter DI?
What?
It's time to stop.
one and done one and done here again one and done yeah I
don't time I believe soon all right what's the next
character Honda we see that playtime on it new challenger
holy that's cheating you never click this character in his
life my goat I'm gonna play a poor diamond player I don't
know how much does an MMR work in this game if you don't
play a character I was trying to coach you Karkeu I know I
could get Honda the master easy trust what rank what's your
opponent's rank now I know he set you up Karkeu he's gonna
be like a black player he's gonna fight a black player he
literally set you up Karkeu he More one slims.
We really just didn't have a chance from the show.
What are you talking about?
Shine doesn't even know anything about Honda, bro.
Like, no, I do.
I can't play the character coaching a guy on the character.
I can play.
You haven't even seen my Honda yet.
See, this is why I didn't pick up Honda again.
I would have been just like you, Kakyu.
You knew right away.
I knew right away.
Imagine.
Imagine I would have been just like you, Kariku.
Oh, man.
That's crazy.
Thank God.
Should I try to get me?
Should I try to put me back on Honda?
And I was like, no.
At what button you're going to press?
Uh-huh.
Oh.
It doesn't have a combo.
Oh, wait.
This diamond player is hitting you.
Oh.
Oh, you're gonna lose this guy, bro.
Why'd they give me this guy?
Oh, I don't know because he doesn't know the combo.
He doesn't know the combo.
He does zero combo.
It's like me when I play Honda.
He doesn't know the combo.
I think it's a quarter circle kick, just letting you know
for next time.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
No, we're talking here.
It's kind of just coaching.
I'll take my I'll take my coaching fee after.
Yeah.
Oh, you're burning.
Oh, you're burning!
Oh, you're so- I'm winning.
You're like, on that next drill.
God, bro.
That's the most HP he's ever lost, too, and all those
fights, I guess the diamond player.
Oh, wrong, wrong, wrong answer.
Yeah.
Oh Shine you're kind of getting cooked right now like I have
a round though.
He doesn't have a round Come on.
Oh, oh, he's got it.
Oh, he's got it.
Stop into that now.
Oh, he's he's trying he's figuring up Honda's tech right now
live on stream Wait, he doesn't know combos and he try to
coach you car queue.
That's what I'm saying Come on, you see the Honda though
Look at the E hand.
Oh, you literally just won out of sheer luck.
Don't sheer luck.
Cheer fundamentals.
I understand the character, the game, how to play, how to do
it.
Come on.
Parky, you were always in good hands.
You were always in good hands.
I got on the ones on Honda.
Parky lost every game.
How is he in good hands?
I think if I did have Mickey helping me out, it would have
been GGs.
It would have been.
help you what that's crazy i i spent a lot of hours i spent
the most time on you because i asked i requested shine
thinks that just because he spent a lot of time that means
that he coached good like bro you just like mickey what
she's saying is that mickey did what you couldn't do one
last time then you did it well you didn't i guess but that's
a lie and she knows it how do you know that yo you gonna
play what are you doing what are you doing Kimberly there's
still one left there's last one last one put my outfit on
bro i wouldn't pretend it's me
so she can feel like she's winning put my outfit on shine
what are you doing
on no this is this is all me bro put the swimsuit on bro yes
we all need a common enemy and our common enemy is shy
literally that is crazy bro you don't have the okay you have
the outfit i was about to say no put my color on what are
you doing no no you're asking for too much i'll put the
swimsuit on that's all she wanted i'm gonna use my she is
depressed right now we are not in the I worked so hard.
I worked so hard.
He doesn't care about us, guys.
He doesn't.
He doesn't care about us.
I mean, we could just...
How do we get from point A to point B exactly?
Let's all apply for new challenges and then hope another
coach pick us all for up.
Yeah.
I'm going to email them back and be like, no shine, please.
No shine, not to take me.
Please.
You don't.
You don't mean that.
I mean that.
Don't pick me next time, bro.
Don't.
Now you got Frank Bison with his ugly ass outfit on bro.
Look at this That is crazy.
You don't mean that I didn't say that don't kid me bro.
I want to go back to nephew Nephew team was a winning right
now.
Nephew team is gonna win.
That's why I went to Japan on team nephew I went to Japan on
team nephew too.
Oh my god.
We found the common denominator It's nephew It's nephew all
alive No way nephew sent us all to Japan Kyle, Kyle, when
you apply to new challenges next, write on the extra info,
please nephew pick me.
I would honestly, I would rather, I'd rather lose with shine
than, you know, like, you know, they go to Japan with
nephew?
They go to Japan?
Yeah, this is my home.
Team shine is my home.
I have one loyal member.
One loyal member.
Well, to be fair, he did help, he did help him, he, he did
tell him to change his the guy then you know it might not
have been as pretty to be fair do you know why he told you
change the guy because i gave intel to shine the day before
the tournament i'm watching oh yeah it's just doing the mows
right now are you watching he's literally doing them all he
dropped the combo are you watching he's doing the mows um
wait so i'm sorry doki you watched me be bad and then No, I
was looking at the profiles of everybody in beginner tier,
and I saw what characters they're playing, and I told Shine,
and then he was like, yeah, I'm going to, I should make you
swap the Saga instead after I gave him Intel.
You said I'm concerned about this guy.
No, no, I was saying...
Are you guys watching?
I'm watching.
I am watching.
I am enjoying it.
I can multitask.
Oh, my God.
He's not trying not talking now.
What's going on?
Yeah, Chad's not talking When he starts losing oh Can you
guys continue your conversation?
This is all this is all isn't this his main?
Yes No,
oh my god, I dropped my combo hold on he's gonna lose he's
gonna he has performance anxiety oh oh hold on i got wait oh
oh no come on bad bad combo shine no it's a good combo okay
come on you're watching right you're watching why everyone
told tyler all the time wait why didn't you teach feisty
this yeah i don't know he literally they didn't he didn't
teach me anything all he taught me was throw more throw more
i'm like okay bro like
don't rematch no rematch one and done him you're not getting
it lp get out you're not getting lp quit now everyone's
gonna now everyone's gonna call you a one and done here on
reddit i'm four for four that was cool though that was cool
yeah i guess that was so cool i guess it was cool what you
want yeah well not the honda part the honda was little rough
i will say the honda the honda was a little concerning i
think the honda cooked damn guys wait guys we still get
money for participating yeah we do wait we get the
participation medal all right we thought it was just a trip
to orlando was like oh no no it's free money we participated
we got four so we get 250 each Okay, I'm getting extra
avocado extra guac on my next burrito.
Yeah, yeah, let's go Look what shine's pulling up.
What did shine pull up our score?
That wasn't in I was just trying to see the discord.
I was trying to know that was my discord Wow
You just remember it.
No, I was trying to pull up the discord relax.
We could have been a reminder shine we could have been zero
points we could have honestly we could have we were we were
close we were so close but look at that we as a team
together did not crash out no we stayed strong with the good
vibes i hope i get to see all of you guys again not shine
but i hope all
i'm joking unfortunately i will still be seeing shine in
orlando that's the worst part we lost and i'm still seeing
him in orlando man i'm just trying that is a saying word you
don't mean that it's okay it's okay shine i i'm glad you
were there for us during why is that pain you so much to say
i know you know you you were very slow on saying that almost
as if you pained you i am I'm really happy.
Shine, you know, you know, Shine, you were here, you gave us
the vibes, you know?
You brought the vibes.
We would not have as much fun with any other coach, but you,
Shine.
Yeah, we would be winning with other coaches.
Yeah.
But the vibes, yeah.
You know?
I see.
That's right.
You know, it's true.
Like we wouldn't win, but like, at least we had fun, you
know?
Yeah.
I think that's priceless, no?
It gets priceless.
The memories we made together.
Along the way.
Exactly.
We could have made memories in Orlando together though.
Next time, next time, next time.
We guys, we could have gotten Disneyland together.
We could have gotten.
Holding hands.
We could have gotten a Disneyland.
Holding hands with Mickey, all of us.
Yeah.
I see.
Not shy though.
not sorry no not wait so even if you made it i wouldn't go
either that's great no we would be we would buy four tickets
to disneyland and then wouldn't i mean you know you know uh
when we when we won with nephew they didn't send nephew to
japan yeah they didn't send nephew to japan wait really yeah
yeah yeah so i don't think shan would have gotten through
wait would which but i would have been there though because
i'm going anyway oh yeah but like you know disney is
different though we got things to do yeah yeah we would have
gone with Andy we would have been like we'd bring Andy alive
not shine we would oh my god posting pictures tagging shine
to fuck it man tag shine I wish you were here even though I
am already in a postcard postcard too we would all tweet a
photo it's pretty close it's pretty close to disney world
too right we would all tweet a photo and be like too bad
shine couldn't join us yeah it sucks it sucks and then we
bring like nephew along or something all the coaches except
him yeah yeah i can deliver the postcard in person yeah i'll
see him in the tournament oh i'll give a time like that i
wish you were there bro that was yeah i wish you were there
too bad you got that was so cool with us yeah all right guys
i gotta bounce ggs ggs guys take it easy everybody thanks
for playing everybody i had a great time i had a great time
i had a great time you know what great way to end the day
two losses losing in an overall and losing in oh yeah no i
got my i knew what was going happen in street fighting but i
just wanted to win one game surprisingly i thought i was
going to win the bricky game and then i ended up winning the
ricky game so you know in the end i still got my one game
out it would it wouldn't matter yeah it would you played
really good you played well i just need to warm up i just
need to get it's always the first game that i'm always like
you know what we should do listen we all get on overwatch
yeah oh yeah we got car cute we got car cute he's gonna make
an educational video for it i got you guys honestly i think
there's a better coach honestly yeah that would be perfect
shine will be the tank all right yeah i can play support we
just have this one random also play support yeah you know
let's all boot up overwatch right now guys i'm about to swap
oh yeah come on kyle get into overwatch with us kyle let's
all play one game account and everything you don't have to
you never played overwatch you never played overwatch no i'd
have to like make a whole new account oh it's okay it's free
to play it's true it's free to play download overwatch right
now let's all get it and hop on overwatch guys listen i'm
down i'm down genuinely We need a win.
We need a win here.
Parker, you're going to carry us, right?
Okay, okay.
Yo, hop on right now.
All right, hop on.
I'll send my battle tag.
Let's go.
I was going to say I'm bouncing, because I'm going to do an
overwatch.
You're going to hop on.
Shine, come on.
I feel like I've been peer pressured to do everything else
today.
I feel like I have to.
Yeah.
Yes.
That's my battle tag.
Add me.
We're hopping on Overwatch now.
You're probably going to have to mute my mic because my
keyboard is so loud.
the way you know holy this is the content people really
wanted yes this is this is the real team bonding experience
exactly it has to download content you know i haven't
downloaded bro hasn't even patched the game you haven't seen
the new hero yet it's back on overwatch your you should
update quickly right you got a good internet yeah i got i
got feebray oh you got feebray for wow if only fee yeah
capcom didn't know but that's how that's how he parseced
over on my account and capcom didn't know but we were
building an overwatch team all right i'm booting it up
someone add wait did you guys send it oh yeah i added you i
i can i can send you by tag but i can also add you all add
us all right let me oh my god we're trying to still screen
sharing and i'm watching him download like updating
overwatch right now uh yeah it's updating right here at me
man i'm going as far away as you are you can see are you are
you really downloading it too kyle you're staying on for it
what a time one wow look at us go i don't know how we ended
up here look at us go man they're playing the playoffs we're
about to get into it yeah we're building friendship we're
built you think they'll talk to each other after first time
playing overwatch hold up i mean you like my non-sagat hmm
let me think about this you know what look at the heroes
yeah yeah you know what he should play junk rat that's what
it is oh that's true that's the guy right there spam and
fireballs
all right this is this is gonna be a they must be capcom
must be so used at us right now i mean i don't think they
need us anymore we could we could have just ended our stream
no no we uh that would be boring exactly that's why we don't
want to bring you to i bet you our team our team was the
most fun to watch out of everybody right here i agree i
agree i agree we had the vibes no other team was like us
guys true i think this was one of a kind or I bet when
they're like, what did you remember about new challenges?
They would be like, oh, shine steam.
Oh, my God.
They wear something, all right.
Oh, wait, there's Street Fighter skins in the game.
I don't know if you've been playing since.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There is.
I don't have any of them, though.
Wait, Karik, you are animating?
Yeah, I used to be.
I'm playing a long time.
Man, that's me too, though.
You want Anna?
You're going to take my...
i'm in no no no i can play anything wait are you guys
already in can i can i can i spectate while i well this is
expecting what that's gonna that's gonna make the download
go slower he's got bebrae yeah he's got bebrae i'm just
staring on my wallpaper you know like i need some type of
content you know all right i'm i'm feeling how deep in your
download are you kyle are you are you joining us bro he's
just watching it okay he's 31 percent sorry i'm i'm a
basically at the same rate as shine is oh okay you can
definitely do one yeah we can yeah we'll give you a uh
step-by-step commentary on what's going on so guys let's go
let's go to ranked so i wish so we could do the longest skew
ever how about that all right invite me car queue let me
invite you i got you guys invite invite because i think i'm
a pure offline i could never tell
your game is still set to street fighter 6 who's fun feisty
no it's not right now you're spectating feisty she just
changed that i saw wow i literally just changed it i didn't
just change it why are you lying on my name right now i just
don't even understand because you didn't change the title
either i mean yeah i didn't change the title i'm not going
to what why would i change the title bro are you are you
online feisty or no yeah i know i don't even think we're in
i don't there's no way we would be able to play rank
definitely i'm uh my off roles are in masters if you guys
are on diamond it should work i'm gm okay guys i don't want
to talk about it why is it so laggy okay i could play tank
but it's not gonna be pretty it's not i think my tank is
masters oh it's my match everything is why match
it's all right we have quick play we have quick play we have
quick play you know what i'll i'll do all i'll do all i'll
do everything but see that's not all that's not i mean i
can't you said i couldn't do it you said i couldn't do tank
oh okay it said wide for everything yeah oh wait no this
isn't it yeah i quit quick play now i swapped i can't play
tank guys don't it's not gonna go well you might like hazard
he's fast he's slippery we should push shine on tank we
should put him on wait you play play overwatch feisty wait
you got the table flip hold up yeah i played more than me
last season yeah i couldn't i gave up i i did not care about
the table flip i gave up yeah that's too many i didn't even
play enough last season what the played tank so it was you
know yeah you're gonna know how we feel when we play street
fighter what do you mean what do you mean by that what do
you mean by that oh i got tank all right i'll play the new
map yeah i got support oh god i hate this new map is so bad
it's like hanamura but like more i just don't even
understand it like i didn't like the choke point for it it's
a little weird my game look extremely laggy on stream i hope
it's not do you guys find it weird that i play this game
with my keyboard my keyboard on my i think i might be in
kirk yeah whoa oh my god my games yo why is my game so laggy
on stream what the do you have do you use a game capture
yeah i was do you run obs on admin mode or no i don't think
so usually it doesn't require it but i know when i play like
apex or some other games i have to do it on i don't know why
it's slagging though like oh we're defense i haven't been
defense yet slagging bad or maybe maybe you have a memory
leak are you on borderless wind yeah yeah so shine one one
hello yeah wait what happened yeah what's what is it kyle
here's why you got you got one hand on your lap and one hand
on the desk is that what you're saying Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
That's why he wasn't coaching us.
He was too busy doing other things.
He asked if that was weird, and I'll confirm that is weird.
I do think that is weird.
Oh, yeah, I mean, it's just the way I've gotten comfortable.
Like, I don't know, before I upgraded my desk setup, I
didn't have enough space on my desk to do both, so I used
the keyboard on my lap.
Whoa!
Sorry, you're so busy.
My stream is running at a nice 5 FPS.
Let's go.
go let's go are you still are you streaming on discord or
something i'm on i'm streaming it on discord right now yeah
oh my god i just had this new character bro oh she on she's
like really good inside these five but apparently i found
out she's bad at 66.
do you play 6v6 oh i had to for the tournament today oh i
see yeah yo is my keyboard too loud or mine too loud no
you're No, they're five.
I can barely hear it.
I can't even hear it either.
I'm gonna die.
Cause Ash is low.
Yeah, you were on five.
Have you ever heard Huntress's keyboard?
No.
Yeah.
I don't know.
You're so healthy.
I might just be racist.
Holy shit.
Literally, why am I lagging so bad?
You might have to maybe restart stream.
Damn, at that point I'll just end it, bro.
Do you have a frame limit?
Do you have FPS limit on it?
I don't think so.
Okay, limit your FPS.
Maybe that's why.
He's up.
Ryan's low.
Yo, why is there always a Ryan hoarding quick play?
Isn't that crazy?
Like, it's the only way they'll enjoy Ryan.
I was playing a lot of rank yesterday, though.
He is, uh, he's kind of back.
He's pretty good this season.
Yeah.
Yeah, they buffed his fire strike at two taps.
I'm so laggy, I know.
Try limit your F frames.
Oh, it's because my game is done downloading.
Oh, let me see.
We're gonna have a team player.
This guy's about to play Ryan, isn't he?
All right.
No, I play Ramatra and Sigma.
I mean, Sigma is basically a ride.
Oh, I'm in.
Oh, you're in there.
That ride has shattered, though, so good luck.
He's about to solo shatter me, by the way.
Oh, I'm getting chased.
He's bad, and it's so loud.
Oh, my God.
I'm dead.
If you speak me.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, you're dead.
Never mind.
Oh, my God.
Shines thing is playing right now on my side.
Oh my god.
I forgot I still have his screen share open.
Oh, I'm screen sharing still?
What?
Oh, maybe.
Wait, is that it?
Actually, no, it can't be.
No way.
Are you watching his stream?
Yeah, we are.
No way.
Wait, are you on GPU?
I got you.
What is this, bro?
I can't save you forever.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, that's okay.
guys this rhymes in katune rush he's way too fast he's
swinging he's swinging all right guys we need a full health
if we full health then shine and kyle can join us damn bro
i'm uh 110 away from be all right i believe oh wait yeah you
gotta do like training your audience will love the overwatch
yeah yeah yeah trust trust oh we're just making a comeback
right now a lot of people that have played it before so
they'll know what they're looking at i'm missing out on the
free overwatch drops right now no i'm on you ever wonder you
ever wonder capcom is really confused in this chat right now
what we're doing everyone's code is why are they all still
in here we are finding this is the old don't they like that
we're making okay it's okay okay thank you thank you i'm
just gonna go trade my life we'll take this trade here okay
no one i'm out all right listen i think also street fighter
is an official partner with overwatch so we're technically
yeah yeah so we are like promoting yeah we got what do we
have we have cami we have we have ryu yeah we got jury we
got chun we got chun we got shine put shine on juno oh i've
never played juno yet my kiriko though is done we got Blanca
on Winston oh you gotta play for playing tank you go you go
Winston yeah I can't play Winston either wait what my hero
pool is very limited in this game though so you can still
watch I got tips and tricks yeah that's a good guy it's too
laggy that's fine it's okay um you are it's okay guys I'm
playing kda yep i'm playing kda that was me during the
tournament too i think that's a league of legends group but
you know i'll fight you okay i was i was ending stream i was
ending stream i had to i had to this is too laggy people
over appreciate it haven't you streamed them played
overwatch before i have but this is this is what did
overwatch play before yeah yeah but i'm in the u.s I don't
know.
I haven't played on this PC before.
So I got you.
Oh, it's not like set up properly.
Yeah, it's not set up properly at all Wait, what what's your
GPU?
What bro?
This game is so laggy bro.
Oh my god.
What's your GPU right now?
It's loud as loud as not laggy.
It's fine.
Your in-game isn't laggy though, right?
No, my in-game is fine Okay, okay.
So it was just whoa Wow
Oh, our hot our Hanso was sad you were afk the moment oh he
he's colon seeing whoa i'm trying to keep feisty up if i
keep feisty up the whole world would be alive yes i think
you guys should move so we can all play together don't worry
we're gonna die i'm gonna die i gotta like make a loser to
count still it stinks i'll be right there okay oh yeah it's
all right there's a kusune rush oh my god they have a
million ultimates in my face here yeah you're dead you're
dead it's fine it's fine i'm locked in now feisty we
actually never mind this is we it's too late to lock it it's
too late i forget i forget this is not ranked i forgot i
forgot i thought we were switching sides guys i'm sorry i
switched inside my bad it might be a little too late feisty
you can tell when feisty was starting to fix or pc in the
stack I literally didn't do anything Wait, they're like big
fan of your work Karku and Doki What about feisty?
Wow, what about feisty?
What the hell?
Yeah, it's crazy, man Zero appreciation out here This is
just Excuse me, feisty got us 20 points God appreciate it if
it wasn't for feisty we would have had 10 points don't worry
you guys I got a blue Juno skin from a blue box what about
that Chun Lee skin whoa true I wasn't playing yet because I
played this game on and off I wasn't playing yeah when when
the skins came out I'm sad I'm on the game can someone
invite or should we should we wait for for Kyle Kyle has to
make an account I mean, it shouldn't be a tutorial too.
We'll have to see a tutorial.
Oh wait, you have to do a tutorial You have to like be
soldier in the training range.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I really don't you like can't you like skip that
though I don't know what the first you want him to skip that
like we can like give him the IRL tutorial, you know, like
we can help him out
Oh my god.
I'm gonna be doing a I just got you guys put you put SF in
your name.
It's like people writing oh shine sf oh my god yeah i mean
and nyc was taken unfortunately man dude his career profile
was private he doesn't want anyone guys what mine oh i could
i could make i can unprivate it's not supposed to be private
how do i unprivate it uh social uh you have to go to options
social options social privacy tab and then career profile
visibility in the end too shine Yeah, I agree.
Yeah.
Where is it?
Privacy, then what?
Oh, it's on friends only, so we're just not friends.
Whoa.
I guess we're not friends, bro.
I guess we're not friends.
I mean, after this tournament, I'd be surprised.
That's what I'm saying.
Wait, shine out of me!
Shine out of me!
No one wants to be my friend.
I accept that you're a friend.
added you yeah i added you yeah i added you already okay
that's fine yeah now let's see that career profile shine
only quick plane what is this he's a quick play warrior for
this for this season i used to play before wait wait let me
check oh let me look okay he was golden season 2026 he was
plat wow you peak he peaked diamond oh i see it east oh my
god God wait hmm will you shine 200 games no look at season
two feisty that's crazy season high I don't even know silver
silver how did season season high silver three finals silver
five wait what what do you mean I'm confused wait what's the
issue here exactly you yeah but like what's the issue here
i'm just very i'm really proud of you for improving so much
within a year there was a season in there a year and a half
that is good season in there i got master guides i mean
those are the time where i had to learn how to play on
keyboard exactly i used to play on console wait what was
your ranking console um it was it was also diamond but
in all that's so true there's more realistically that's
progress you know yeah that's what i'm saying i was like i
was like i'm proud of you for for improving a lot for being
your first was it your first mouse and keyboard fps game yes
it was actually oh guys what's going on i've i've i grew up
playing on console controllers oh god oh you gotta pick a oh
yeah every time i play a game like this area and I always
have to big tank I know you don't have to I'll play tank if
you want I am right try the new character oh oh rat justice
we have we have Kyle stop the wait oh cancel yeah cancel the
queue rat justice we got rat justice in here get that man in
here do you think I would have done better than tournament
if I was called rat justice I think so yeah I think so that
that name is kind of intimidating it's weird I'm a first and
last name I was the only one Because Karku has the role
thing where I can invite friends.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Give me the leader, and then I'll give it back to you.
Okay.
She's going to disband the group.
Wait, where'd you put your B-tag?
I don't even see it.
Oh, no, he just added me because I had my B-tag.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He just added us.
Oh, I got it.
Okay, and then...
Oh, I see.
And then I give you the leader again.
I turned off all my alerts.
Karku, why weren't you in the Overwatch tournament?
Uh...
I wasn't invited.
Me neither.
No, Pisces, you were invited.
I forgot about it.
Bro, I was invited, but then Boger was like, you have a
tournament on the same day.
And then they, he was like, do you want to do, I did both.
He didn't, I mean, he didn't ask me if I wanted to do both.
I was, yeah, I don't know.
He didn't want me to do that bad.
It's okay.
Your name is Rat Justice.
I feel like at this point you have to play junk rat.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay.
I might as well just play support.
Sorry, is that damage or support?
I don't know.
That is a damage character.
Hold on.
When we queue up, I'll bring us into the range and you're
going to just click the hero and you'll figure it out.
It's like sagat training all over again.
Yeah.
Hold on.
Oh my God.
I just got invited to a...
Hopefully the queue doesn't pop too fast, but...
Guys, I think I have another two tournaments next week,
guys.
Oh, that sounds like so much fun.
I just got invited to an Apex tournament next week, guys.
Man, can you tell them to invite me to?
Technically, I'm looking for two teammates.
Oh, I'm good at it.
Me and Punk.
Me and Punk are actually very good at that.
Yeah, man, we can be Team Shine all over again, but we can
win that actually.
What do you mean by that?
Time returning with W.
You don't mean that.
Wait, I can grab all Team Shine in there.
And then we'll fight Shine and Kyle.
We'll be...
We'll put Shine and Kyle.
Hey, Kyle chose his side.
He chose...
I used to think with Shine.
He chose the DPS icon.
Junkrats in the specialist area.
All right, there you go.
Five ammo, and those things, if you hit a direct, they do a
lot, and they can bounce off walls.
Cool.
Look at Shine practicing his tanking abilities.
Look at him.
Look at him go.
We're going to bring Kyle into the Overwatch.
Everyone is so condescending towards my Ramatra.
actually be supportive feisty was the one also very
supportive i didn't finish my sentence but yeah exactly
exactly he reacted before i could finish my sentence my
fault my fault what is this friendly fire feisty you know
we're used to you know yeah we are we are you know we're a
team being called out by people like shine you know hated on
what that's why i'm guarded you know i keep my guard up
Kyle, there's only, this hero is pretty simple.
You just spam your gun.
That's all he has.
And then your shift is your next most important ability.
So that's a mine.
You have to press it once, and it'll stick to walls.
And if you press right click, once it's out, it'll detonate.
So shift, and then right click.
Carkew is such a good coach.
So that will boot people.
And you can use it on yourself for movement.
But we don't have to worry about that at the beginning.
at a time oh never mind you got down whoa he's a natural
wait he's just a natural yeah honestly i think if i think if
kyle had two days okay here we go what is it what is it i
think if kyle had two days on sagat he would have switched
beginner tier easily easily another 24 hours exactly i was
okay it was a late minute call yeah for sure then your e is
uh just a trap if So let me just teach you the really quick
combo for Junkrat.
Nobody can step on it because we're all teammates now.
But what you're going to do is when you're up in someone's
face, left click, shift, right click as fast as you can.
Oh.
Exactly.
But like that, so that mine will do damage.
So come to one of these bots over here.
I'm going to ping it on the right.
I actually come over here.
Guys, I'm going to ping this right here.
I don't really know much about Kyle's background.
I saw someone in...
You're going to see his bot?
You're going to left click?
I saw someone mentioned that Kyle knows the game of war.
like he's like adrenaline or game awards people like the
mine didn't even reach him so that was the right idea you
can actually delay the mine a little bit depending on the
distance i don't like karki and feisty and shine but i don't
know much about kyle cool i like that you see how much
damage you just did yeah yeah it was half his meter the
first time but then almost like 95 the second i don't know
go in there shine is he i don't know i saw someone mention
it offhand wait what happened oh that's all right never mind
man what am i doing all right so Sorry, I was getting no
clue.
But he seems cool.
Now, unfortunately, that combo doesn't one-shot a lot of
people in the roster.
They'll live with like 5 HP.
So then the level three of this is like, you shoot, you hit
the mine, they get bounced in the air, and you hit the third
shot in the air, which is kind of hard.
But if you do it first try here, I'm going to give you 10
subs.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Right here.
Okay, you see?
I believe, Kyle.
I believe.
If you do it first, I'm going to send you to the team.
Disney yeah Kyle is it true that you work with Jeff at the
game awards you know Jeff W oh my god can you guys invite to
the game awards now that we're now that we're all friends
now that we're all friends here Kyle yeah wait what do you
do for the game awards uh like writing like uh wait you
write you write the scripts sometimes yeah wait what you're
telling me he's reading a teleprompter and not doing it from
the top i can't believe you write the muppets my immersion
i've written a muppets joke before wait is that what oh i
thought no that meant the miss piggy and jeff thing i didn't
get to write any miss piggy jokes uh what kind of stuff did
you wrote i did write Give us one of them that got rejected.
What was one thing in the script that got rejected?
That's a really good...
So, they're pitches, right?
You make your pitches, and none of it actually gets in the
script.
But, like, I don't know.
Like, I forget.
Honestly, this is going to sound really bad as, like, the
pitch.
But it was, like, you know, like, friend slop was a really
popular phrase at the end of last year.
Pigs love slop.
You know, there's something there.
Oh, okay.
There's something there.
there's something there right whoa you're gonna make miss
piggy say that you well no that didn't get it didn't get
picked they did not like yeah but like who was gonna say it
was jeff to miss piggy or miss piggy to jeff i mean like
yeah yeah like jeff will make the call but like miss piggy
gets some input oh we get arctic peninsula bro this is crazy
we had lijang up there what
Did you write for this year's Game Awards?
Oh, the screen is different.
Or like, not last year's Game Awards.
Last year, yeah, yeah.
I'm so cool, Kyle.
That is very cool.
Oh my god, Kyle.
He's trying to get in.
It is cool.
What does it mean?
We just, we have someone that works with Jeff.
I agree.
That's cool.
I'll play Mizuki.
just one more mission uh so what are we doing what do we
focus on oh yeah so let's explain the game modes this is
king of the hill there's going to be a big rectangular
rectangular point in the middle we just have to have control
of it yes you don't have to stand in it once it's captured
like you can leave it we are one degree away contested by
standing in it you do have to stand in it after we're nearly
one degree away from yeah do it perfect spirit i would say
for your first game ever of Overwatch, just play a little
far and just like spam the grenades where you think they
are.
It's like random bullshit type deal.
What a good way to...
What the fuck?
Are Diva, their Diva's...
Their Diva's special.
My god, what is going on bro?
That was so funny.
Yeah, I was like, where did he come from?
Whoa.
Yeah.
I'm in there.
Yeah, you are.
So this is the point.
It's on the ground.
Let's go!
Rat Justice!
Oh my god!
I'm coming to help you.
I'm coming over too.
I'm sorry, I couldn't get you.
You got, you were so far away.
One kill, I'm happy.
I'm happy.
Oh my god.
You got a kill?
It's like when you got that one round off in Street Fighter,
imagine it's just like that.
Honestly, I like Street Fighter more than this, but this is
still fun too.
You say that now, but this is your first game.
It's your first game.
or no no so you know like i'm a variety streamer where most
of the stuff i stream is like silly you know yeah oh this
game can get silly though it can get real silly especially
it can get addicting like numbers go up type deal you know
like i have a bike right now not like who they did i never
thought they would do it but they did it i have a motorcycle
i'm so dead man You're not dead.
You might be dead.
You're dead.
I'm sorry.
I'm flanking their back line.
Give me a second here.
Hold up.
We hang low.
I- Oh, I got him!
Let's go!
We can do this!
I'm going.
Where's their squishies?
Dang, you two just defended it on your own.
That's so sweet.
Yeah, see?
It gets silly.
That's what I'm saying.
They're trying hard.
What do you mean?
I'm spinning around.
I'm- We're literally- We're just surviving.
Oh, there we go.
Give me that shit.
Let's go.
I'm in.
Oh, I'm running.
That will kill you.
That will kill you, Kyle.
That will kill...
Okay, thanks for...
I know you saw that.
Oh, what?
I tried.
What do you mean, bro?
I slept a baby diva so she couldn't get back into the back?
Come on, man.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
He's addicted to not giving me credit.
Oh, you're gonna die.
You're literally gonna die.
When she's out of the suit?
Yes, we do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We call her a baby.
Call her a baby.
little pippy itty baby oh that's good you got her don't
worry i'm helping i'm helping i'm helping i'm on the high
ground there one over there yeah look at us look at us look
at us go that's what winning feels like guys
we are a team maybe we're secretly an overwatch team yeah
this whole time that's what i'm saying they might have
accidentally put together the best the best guys i think we
could go to owcs guys i agree i could we should sign up on
face it y'all i agree yeah let's do a face i was like yo
your chat's hyping you up like that's actually really that's
solid they are they say hell yeah they say hell yes hell
yeah that's why I like hell yes hell yeah and they say this
is sweet and wholesome too actually ah all right so we're in
a big submarine here a big yellow submarine I don't know if
we live in it oh wait Qian's one I got her no it's uh there
Laurie's dead so this is the 5v5 so we're up 5v3 this is
where we No, no, we don't have to sit on point and, uh, that
cast is what, yes.
You don't have to sit on point.
You can just get super aggressive since we're up on numbers.
I'll push up here.
Coming over.
There we go.
You only have Ana here.
I'm almost back, guys.
Oh, I can shoot the penguin.
Yeah, you can.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently the new map, there's bees and the bees can kill
you.
Do you shoot at it?
Yeah.
Oh, they're running.
Mora.
Now it's real random.
Oh there.
Sorry, I'm gonna spear into them.
Hold on.
I don't even know where I am.
Oh, wow.
Alright.
I don't know where I was.
Where's that guy?
Oh my god, he was so low.
Sorry, I was trying to...
I'm super low here.
Anybody's got these?
I got you.
There's a hat.
I gave you a hat.
Fine, I was trying to kill the Diva.
I was trying to kill Mora, but I missed every shot that
mattered.
Okay, to be fair, I got her one and I missed every shot.
I don't have another...
I do have another hat.
what do i get here oh this oh sorry i was too busy looking
at my stats that's okay
what's the lalt button lalt what's that mean what oh left
alt it's uh left all left alt yeah on your keyboard wait
what button is that wait why why is it asking you to do that
i'm drunk right i got a perk oh oh god that's new ish in the
last year wait have you ever played overwatch before kyle no
this is my first time oh what is the diva doing bro this is
just dpi switching this is killing me bro so you have to
hold the left alt and then like pick left or right i
actually play zero drunk i don't even know what's going on i
think it's the attack speed one sorry i got way too cocky
there i wanted that kill here you want give kyle the oh
putting going in the highlight reel oh never mind i did wait
who did you nano Car Q, what do you mean?
You should have nanoed Kyle.
You should have nano Kyle.
I did nothing with it.
My B, my B.
I wasn't gonna nano shine, that's for sure.
Why, why not?
I don't know.
I haven't seen you do much, man.
What do you mean?
I was cooking people.
I was definitely cooking people.
They have mail here.
Oh, that's a Diva bomb.
Watch out for that.
Remember, that kills.
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't realize how far.
Oh, that's the killer.
All right, you guys ready?
We got picked.
I'm ready.
I'm putting the wall.
I shine 3K right here.
I'm going to watch you go.
Yeah, yeah, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, no fear.
The killer for that?
We're going to be frozen in mid.
It's okay.
I accidentally jumped out of my alt somehow.
Oh, I'm cooked.
I don't know how I jumped out of my alt.
I forgot the shift does a giant nice jump just a little bit
yeah so they're winning because of using alts really well is
that what just happened yeah yeah yeah they had a really
good male that froze us but that's okay so it's an almost
time we have to touch to trigger overtime I can do it I
might have to touch yeah I have a yeah I might die for this
though so you got me who's next somebody get next somebody
get next all right I'm in I'm in nice i'm gonna die i died
here yeah that was a shine from the lar it's okay oh my god
she's one we lost so we could have another round you know
that's how it goes i was cooking i was cooking too man yeah
i was cooking as well yeah i can't i can't speak for all y
'all we were all cooking but but i was cooking though for
sure at the end there you should have seen me go it's okay
we win this one yeah we win this one
you know what after this after this we will um each rank up
on our own account so we can all play together master right
with you guys we yeah we all grab me feisty car queue we'll
get an alt account and then we can all five stack and rank
okay yeah yeah and we'll take all of we'll go to masters
guys all the way oh yeah wcs yeah yeah so we could qualify
for base it
what is face it it's the land i don't know what that is
either it's the land equivalent yeah so we can go to japan
yeah i think the next event is in paris right now oh it's a
korea it's i think they moved it i couldn't tell no way
korea that's even better man one down there's a cast on the
left going for him yeah he's don't worry i'll go for him too
yeah you get him oh that diva diva is on the ground though
he's on the ground bitch oh he's dead though he's dead he's
dead yeah he's trying to protect hello i'm riding in whoops
i have a ground pylon oh yeah it's save him world cup is in
Yeah, it is.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
Oh, it's our mind.
Isn't Evo in Paris as well, like in October?
EWC.
EWC and Evo also.
What are you doing, bro?
Apex is also in Paris too.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Everything is in Paris right now.
Come on, Sean.
She's never going to give you another all again if you don't
do anything.
You know that.
I don't have my nemesis for him.
You nailed me right at the end of my nemesis for him.
Like, what you want?
turn you guys steal your turn back come on technically i was
trying to keep you alive because you're dying again by the
way wait there's a there's a mate behind us there's a mate
behind us kyle look behind you kyle right here kill him come
on man i told i told you what i'm doing i put a wall down
that's okay yeah kyle overwatch or translate into fighting
game turns all right kill her everything is on in oh yeah i
would say everything is in paris now We're going to see it,
Kyle.
I like the remote mine.
I like tossing a mine and then hitting right.
Oh, yeah, that's the best part.
Yeah, they can walk over it.
You could just set like a trap somewhere around here.
Maybe they'll walk into it after as they get a little
closer.
Yeah.
Oh, big alt.
Oh, there's someone sneaking in.
May sneaking in behind.
Fuck you and Jeno.
That's all you, Kyle.
We're going for her.
I'm going to use my bike and bump her down.
Did you boop her?
Oh, she's right here.
She's right here.
She's in her invulnerable.
I'm just going to run her over.
Hit her.
Nice, you got her.
The mind got her, yeah.
Let's go.
I might need heals.
Thank you.
I was living by the edge there.
Come on, Shine.
Come on.
Do you see the kill fee?
You see in it.
That's why I said, come on.
Because that's how much I believe in you.
Shine, I'm keeping you alive.
Thank you.
Well, you ran away from me, so.
Oh, I thought you were closest to the point.
I didn't know where you were.
But I was cooking, though.
You seen it.
Yeah, I did.
You were.
They wasted mail.
I'm at 99 till my nano.
I get nano Kyle.
That's true.
Nanocyle.
Oh, you got the beam on me.
Oh, no!
Oh, that's fine.
It's okay.
You got me though.
All right.
It's fine.
We're even.
You get nano Kyle.
Nano Kyle now.
Who needs me?
Nano Kyle for this.
You're boosted.
You're just going in there.
Go in there.
Oh,
no support.
No support.
I'm coming over now.
I'm throwing my pylon.
I hope that hits somebody.
There you go.
Diva, baby Diva low.
Baby Diva low.
There you go.
That should kill her.
Nice.
Kalea the game.
Oh, definitely.
Now it's going to go to the Alari.
Wait, there it is.
It probably will go to the Alari.
Let's go.
Yeah.
The first win.
Look at us.
gotta win 10 plus 10 points let's go plus on our 10 points
we're gonna chip away our minus 26 now i think we really
worked as a team on that one you know i think we did all of
us contributed yeah that's a minus 25 right there now that's
a minus 12 minus 26 yeah yeah it's no longer 26 anymore it's
minus 25 i see yeah all right yeah i guess yeah yeah look at
us guys how do you I'm voting for peanut blood.
Tab, press tab.
Tab in the game.
If you want to look at it right now after the game, you have
to go.
I saw 11 kills, 9 deaths.
I'll take that.
You did good.
Click your profile on the top right corner, and then you're
gonna click that, and then on the top bar you'll see
history, like the on the top tab, and then on the left side
you'll see game reports, like the middle one.
You see it?
uh no but profile top right and then uh history you'll see
like overview progression statistics and history will be
like the fourth one at the top and then honestly like i'm
okay i'm like right clicking on it nothing happened you want
to bask into the yeah you went 11 eliminations two assists
nine deaths two thousand seven hundred damage we positive
yeah we're positive i was crazy guys we have a better record
this game than we did actually we are unstoppable in this
game yeah we're undefeated yeah shine finish your sentence
shine no no finish your what did you want to say shine no no
it's no it's fine
I'm glad we're together guys I'm happy we were a team
together me too Kyle are you enjoying this yeah I think this
is better than a trip to Orlando right I think so too
quality time right now yeah yeah forget motion sickness on
the coasters let's just play this no you know what this guy.
Yeah, don't let me shoehorn you into junk rat.
Just pick a character that looks cool.
Yeah, that you want to play.
You think this character looks cool?
Kyle?
No, I kind of think like it's cool that junk rat doesn't
look cool.
Oh.
You know what I'm saying?
He's extremely unattractive and I think that's appealing.
Oh, I see.
I would say not everybody agrees with that.
There are some junk rat lovers on Overwatch.
Yeah, there is.
I have seen art that I did not sign up to see.
Don't ask me why.
But, like, isn't that in your recommended, though?
It's a for you timeline.
So it was made for you.
Oh, shit.
I mean.
You caught it.
Anyways.
When the algorithm doesn't lie.
Oh.
Yeah, I don't see that on my timeline.
Yeah, Kyle?
No, I'm not lacking.
Oh, hey.
Has anyone else seen the...
Oh, yeah, what was it, Kyle?
I don't have a timeline.
You don't?
Your Twitter?
No.
No Twitter.
You don't do Twitter?
Honestly, good.
You can stay off that platform.
Good for you.
Honestly, yeah.
This is a great call.
Oh, I guess it was like from the Capcom creator's email.
I was going to say.
Is it like...
I got emailed for the Capcom thing.
Yeah, me too.
I think all of us did.
No, I didn't.
You just asked to be in it?
Yeah, I asked to be in it, bro.
They didn't.
Wait, I was like...
They told me...
Yes.
Yeah, wait, wait.
Faisy, what were you going to say?
I was just going to say they told me.
Some people told me that they got emailed.
And I was like, damn, I'm the only one that didn't get it.
email with the i so i applied and i'm like okay they're
definitely not picking me because they didn't email me i
think it's just automatic you just put on the list without
being asked like yeah i guess it could be that also shad who
was first pick give it to us straight who did you pick first
uh it was feisty and he complains about me so much just to
pick me first not it's great I mean, I was trying to put
together the best team ever, and I did, right?
Yeah, that is.
You did.
Technically, you did, because we all went to Japan, the ones
who did this before.
Honestly, it's true.
Honestly, technically, you put the best team together, but
the problem is that you're the coach, you know?
Like, that was a problem.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
He knew you were gonna get into some rough territory, but
you had to take a timeout.
I'm sorry, man.
Was that too much?
I like how you apologize when he's gone.
He's not even here.
He's not even here to defend himself.
He's not even here to hear feisty apologize to him.
That's fucked.
It's okay.
I will apologize again when he's back.
I'm gizzing everywhere.
Oh, no, no.
Oh, okay.
I see.
That's my fault.
Oh, wait.
i'm doing king's row that's a classic yes i love playing in
king's row man
if i see i don't think they're ever gonna put us two
together again that's crazy why not don't say that one thing
i i think when we're two together it might be a little too
intense i i think so that's up it's actually fucked up
all right let's see junk rat yeah I would say the other one
you could probably try if you don't want a junk rat later on
though is probably maybe like Torbjorn or Reaper or soldier
or very like very beginner friendly heroes oh yeah Torbjorn
yeah because Torbjorn has like his own little turret that
does the shooting for you yeah you put the turret down and
you let it do the work And then you can Kuma the enemies.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, exactly.
You jizz all over them.
Yeah.
Click on all your buttons so you know what you're doing.
Oh yeah, that gives you like extra armor and faster fire it.
Yeah, and you, I think you walk faster too, right?
Yeah, you walk faster.
So that's a turret.
It just builds and that'll just shoot enemies for you.
And then you just left click.
Right click, yeah.
You can, if your turret is getting hit, you can like switch
to the hammer.
With the mouse wheel, I think?
Scroll wheel?
Scroll wheel.
You can hammer your turn.
You can repair it, yeah.
Yeah.
We're throwing, guys.
Oh, our team's back.
Your primary fire shoots Cheetos, and then your left click
is Cheetos.
The right click is Triple Cheetos.
It's a shotgun.
Oh, nice anti.
Big anti on the hog.
Shine?
Oh, he's back.
Shine's back.
He doesn't want to talk to us.
Shine, you missed it.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Shai.
Am I going too hard on you?
I'm sorry.
I love you as a coach.
Oh, he's quiet.
He's giving you the silent treatment.
Feisty.
I forgot to hit my microphone.
Shai, she apologized to you.
Did you ever think you see the day?
I didn't hear it.
What happened?
She apologized to you.
Did you ever think you'd see the day?
No.
Stop lying.
No hook.
My Sierra's low.
Isn't that crazy?
I got there, Shion.
I'm going in.
Man.
I don't even know what to do for this.
I'm healing you.
Thank you.
We're both healing you though.
Move up with that.
I'm fucking zooming.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
I'm zooming.
Nice.
Good deals.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Wait, more builds alt so fast.
No, no fucking.
Yeah, they buffed her.
Her orbs used like 50 more now this patch.
No wonder.
They actually buffed her like crazy.
More shit was going hard.
I mean, she was kind of ass for a while.
That's true.
She hasn't been good.
Is that a card that needs to be buffed?
Yes.
For those who don't want any.
I give it to me and I'll get a three.
I'll get three and if I don't so cook.
Oh my god.
Um, did I?
I died.
Oh, I think you lost it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where is she?
Oh, she's out of the high ground.
She's on the.
I see.
I see her.
She's dead now.
You don't, oh my gosh, you're going back in.
Hey, wait, block, block, block, block, block, block, block.
Oh my god.
I don't have to.
You're burnt out.
Don't do it.
I was good to go.
What do you mean?
I was cooking.
You don't have counter DI, but I was living though.
Oh, I'm dead now.
Yeah, because I healed you.
I mean, that's what a team is for, right?
I have to trust you that you would heal me so I can operate.
You trust me?
Sometimes.
No way.
Oh, we're dead.
We're so dead.
You guys are dead.
That's a combo.
Yeah, that's a combo.
Damn, they nailed her.
No way, man.
Oh, that's actually broken.
What?
Yeah, it's really good.
That's why.
give it to the next man i just give it to me with my all
it'll just kill him yeah like shion with any damn like
damage combos goes hard you can call oh yeah i was gonna say
if he's color towards heck i wasn't vibing with the uh the
turret they just destroyed it yeah you have to place it if
you don't know the map or like where to put it down they
will like they will break it so yeah you got a hidey like
yeah you got but it's like more so a max awareness though
What is that?
That is, uh...
It's like a...
Go, go, go, go, go.
Someone's behind us here.
Go, go, go.
Nice.
Oh, nice car queue.
Got two.
Okay, two for one is fine.
We're close to spawn.
There is a hog.
Hog on the mega health pack down there.
Oh, nice ante.
Nice ante.
Yep.
helping you not then i'm sucking i'm sucking i got him i'm
doing more suck action keep sucking keep sucking oh giving
it all i got i'm dead don't worry oh shine oh wait a minute
this is your moment this is your moment they're burnt out
optimal optimal yeah yeah yeah there you go look at it You
trust me, Shine?
I mean, if someone nanos me, I press Q.
I think it's whoever...
I said you trust me.
I asked you if you trust me, though.
I think it's whoever has nano.
I got you.
Fight him, fight him.
Nano is a good ult, you know?
So it...
He doesn't even trust you.
He just trusts the nano.
Yeah, that's crazy.
It's not even you as a person.
That's crazy.
We got five minutes, man.
We got this.
Is that good or bad?
That means we push it into a...
really fast.
So we have five minutes to get to the end, which the end is
like literally right here.
Oh my gosh, that perk where I jumped like 80 miles in the
sky.
Here you go.
Don't worry, I got you, Kyle.
Come back.
Got their echo.
The Freya, they're playing a really annoying comp into junk
rat.
I won't lie.
Keep spreading.
I have all here.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
I'm riding in.
Let's go.
I'm on that Echo.
That Echo is low.
Echo's dead.
Do we have Nano or no?
No, it's okay.
I want to go in anyways.
Yeah, just do it for the fun of it.
She's low as hell anyway.
Oh no, they got Kyle.
That's okay.
You know what?
Not Kyle.
Russa, Russa, Russa.
There you go.
Yay!
Oh, look at that.
Look at us!
Have I convinced you about my Muramatra yet?
We gotta see that in rank.
Yeah.
His eye.
Oh damn!
That's crazy.
All he did was- He doesn't even do- What did he do?
Oh, it's his.
Oh, because it counts as his kill.
Nice seeing you, Karaku.
Wait, are you like famous or something, Karaku?
oh my god look at my objective time holy payload oh my god
pass the nurture princess wow they're voting yeah the hog
i'm also canadian sorry what's the voting do it's just
nothing yeah it's just for vibes yeah okay it's like an ego
it just makes you feel good if you get five uh kyle you said
you said you do like variety silly streams right let me
introduce you to the silliest custom game mode while we
queue up called mauga nipple pve are you ready oh my god
wait they're they're still going they're the tournament is
still going oh that they're still going what wait wait the
tournament nipple pve yeah sorry hold on tournament what the
tournament is still going i'm yeah it must be like super
close or something because that they have to hit like what
was a hundred points or some it's 40 or 40 20 no i think is
they have to reach 70.
oh yeah that must be intense we've been playing overwatch
for like at least an hour plus already okay well just uh if
you've never heard of this custom game mode well you'll see
i've never i'm scared am i the only one who's never heard of
this i've never don't worry none of us have what is this
it's called mauga nipple pve do i have to shoot the nipple
you have to kill the malga he's a raid boss look at his hp
we're in q for a quick play and now are his nipples the weak
point uh now you gotta it's like it's like a raid so there
are ads this is called oh this is crazy what is happening
it's like we're playing world of warcraft right now yeah why
is it a big ass thorbjorn bro there you go i'm gonna die oh
my god i'm dead what is this i don't know the big don't
worry kill the mini bosses once we have enough good malga's
vulnerable now shoot them shoot the nips hit them hit them
look at his hp bring it down bring it down bring it down
this is next objective in three seconds oh yeah oh there's
venture threat yeah mini wait huge anti huge anti Oh, Danty.
Oh, my God.
What is this, bro?
They're just all.
Overwatch players are really bored, so they make fun game
modes like this.
I know there was like, you can play Super Smash Bros.
Oh, I fell off the map.
Yeah, you can do that.
Wow.
Yeah.
How was Shiny?
That's crazy, bro.
There's Super Smash Bros.
on customs as well.
There is.
It's actually pretty good.
I've never really played.
Oh, I'm dead.
it's all up to you guys i'm back he's vulnerable don't worry
shoot the nipples shoot the nipples i'm jizzing on him
perfect is that where his nipples are located wait oh wait i
was shooting the buttons oh no what's going on i don't even
know this is a new version of this i would play this version
of it oh this is this is a little harder now this is a
little harder oh it's up to I think everybody spawns,
though, no?
Oh, wait.
Nice.
I thought we're dead forever.
I've died like eight times already.
I've also died.
Wait, does it affect...
This is what we call...
Oh, my God.
Why is there so many Maulos?
Does it affect our...
Score if we die?
Yeah.
Oh, it's like the...
The rivals lobby stuff, like the Bloodhunt or whatever the
fuck is called.
Oh my god, I'm frozen.
Dude, Mauga's nipples are on me, or something.
I don't know what's...
Yeah, they're lasering, yo.
They have a lot of funny little terms for it.
Oh, no.
It'll be like Zarya gravitatas and like fucking some fun
shit like that.
Why are there feet?
Oh my god, I'm frozen.
Get me out of here.
Get me out of here, bro.
How is Mauga still...
Oh, we got it.
so much help no i took you guys out it could be a little it
could be a little much but that's uh probably as silly as it
gets yeah give us some custom room recommendations carq you
i think this is this is a first for kyle kyle how are you
feeling bro i don't i don't know if you ever experienced
anything like this it's uh you know it's like it's kind of
like it's it's fun to like be the worst one because there's
you know what i mean like i feel like you're like i'm the
little cousin you know bringing you along and all the stuff
oh my gosh apparently brawl pro dc during his game and that
consider is considered a loss for his say damn that's rough
that's pretty rough they don't want to go over i guess yeah
that's that's tough because like you're gonna lose a trip to
orlando bro i mean if that was the match that i Yeah, I
mean, they're still going, though, but it's just one-to-one
right now.
I bring you guys into just our death match while we can.
Yeah, these queues are long because we have a lot of varied,
mixed ranks.
We have a brand new player.
Yeah.
So the matchmaking is a little...
That's okay.
It was a bit laggy to pick your hero, but it's back now.
Okay.
This place is cool.
Is there lore behind this mansion?
e this is widow makers mansion she's like the undead girl
the purple lady sniper all right sniper yeah widow maker oh
we got a game you left the game what happened we're in the
game what do you mean i'm confused i'm confused we do man
i'm holding random bro these maps look terrible except for
ilios but like i'm not voting that yeah i was gonna vote for
Ilius is okay.
I think we got it.
Okay.
No arising at ease.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I will play my Lucio.
Ready.
Let's go.
This is the boot of the hole?
No, it's ruins.
It's not the hole.
Oh, shit.
He's retiring the Ramatra.
Let me see the Zarya here.
I do play the Zarya.
Okay.
all right i'm gonna give you nano if i see oh yeah give me
nano look at my skin we're gonna go speed so cool oh the
kurope yeah we have a new collab oh yeah okay there's like
they do have a lot of collab so there's a 2b there's a near
collab too heck yeah just for that one character no it's for
i don't know vendetta a couple of them yeah a lot of them
that is to be oh i think i have it on right now let me see
oh we on i don't have to do right we on has one they did a
gun them collab too right yeah our mercy was gun them they
have a lot of special it's actually so nice it's actually
nice oh yeah like i didn't buy that one that was when i
didn't buy skins yet i think my first skin was the 2b1
you got bubble for me bro i'm tied oh my goat whoa i'm low
i'm low yeah you are Guys, I'm only Lucio.
Don't get back on the bike.
That's true.
You're just taking a lap.
Don't worry, don't worry.
I'm on the point.
I almost got you.
Sorry, I didn't give you energy.
I ran away like a little bitch.
I'll play Juno.
Conley?
No!
What about- Pisces, no!
We could have...
We couldn't do it on the other, on the other map.
Oh, that's true.
The other map is better for it.
Yeah, I don't want to play Lucio on this one.
It might be bad.
Wait, she out won.
She got his one.
Yeah, but she got out.
I believe in you, Sean.
He's weak.
Oh, I did...
There's a cast on high ground.
On your far right.
Oh, my God.
They're so weak.
They're all so weak.
I'm so good.
We got we're even we're even you're live in there you're
live in there.
They want to go for Kyle Help them.
Yeah, help.
There's just no bugs once you kill him once you break that
bug you can oh Never mind they have a fucking alt.
It's all right.
It's okay.
We are gonna have our alt soon too It's okay.
I'll get a I'll get a health back here and I He's asleep.
He's asleep.
Wait, hold up.
Hold up.
A little this guy carried by light weaver I have all here.
If you have nano you can send it to me.
Okay.
Yeah, I got you.
I got you I even that anti-cast he's so low what the oh life
weaver um there is a she on right behind her shield she
wants to kill me guys oh she's ulting behind watch out wow
oh she's on the grind on the grind on the ground yeah why
did she try to solo hold me are we winning yeah we're
winning we're winning now sort of not really yes we have
shifting don't worry i'm gonna all here hey guys the cats
caught me yeah the cats got you oh my god and he killed
himself china then i am very dead why not yeah you are i got
one back you can just play on point here someone help kyle
he's getting i was healing him yeah that's zarya one of the
farm damage i'm coming over here now don't worry they can't
even take the point because i'm going crazy over here i got
you car queue thank you thank you thank you oh my god they
were so threatened by you too that's actually insane they
actually you actually had so much aura feisty you know maybe
a little too much or maybe too much oh yeah you know what i
respect that oh oh wait kyle just don't peek yet no oh my
bad my bet it's okay it's okay you're
Come up on the whole hill.
It's all right.
Wait, actually, I don't think we can touch.
Oh my god.
We got touch, we got touch.
We got touch?
All right, I'm coming over.
Oh my god.
But we have Juno.
Yeah.
If you touch that 99, then we can do it.
Oh my god, bro.
I was right there.
That's crazy.
How did I not touch that?
I was on it.
They needed to, they needed to give them a plus one.
I think my Joker Queen is about to go dummy though right
now.
You think so?
you swear no okay well
don't worry i'll be lucio you're about to go crazy because
you're about to get the perks this is it all
right i believe in us guys i believe i believe
I'm going to the left.
Oh my god, this cat's in the sky.
That bike hits the cat.
Did it hit him?
No, I didn't.
I miss old Carcu.
He would have hit that.
I know.
Old me.
Back when I wasn't old and washed.
What were those videos?
You make the one, like a tip for...
One tip for every hero.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When are we getting the Shion tip?
Carcu?
Shion tips.
Yeah.
Coming in hot right here.
we're gonna be on his youtube video guys guys don't worry
kyle was getting the hey i gotta feature kyle as the drunk
rat yeah i'm gonna put it in there this cat's one on point i
was looking at my perks i'm not even gonna lie
i don't have a lot of all charge it's gonna be a while if i
see what junk or queen perks am i supposed to take bro no
way they're going bro this is actually crazy you don't get
on your ultimate so you don't ever lose it the other one's
okay though it's not terrible but they have a cassidy so you
want to take the oh you can come unstoppable during it yeah
he's charging whoa oh my god oh my god he really hated you
there i have to reload oh my god they're going at it
Whoa, go in, go in right now before I die.
Don't worry, I'm coming.
I got it.
Yeah, that saved it.
That was sweet.
Oh, and goodbye.
The cat got me.
Bro, no way.
No.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
We worked so hard for that, too.
Hey.
we're gonna go hard me and feisty got the ultimate combo
going in oh wow there's these health oh i accidentally took
it i should be more confident no i want to there are these
health backs that's one that you can take to restore your
health um yeah go oh my god she's so low that she's on so
low
yo i will say that was definitely a lucio diff right there
oh big beat i like it i like it it was huge it was huge it
was actually massive good job look at us look at this girl i
told you about the queen queen going nasty with it
oh my god they're bringing a raid boss in right now i killed
the cat though Great blast, yeah.
Reloading.
He has...
He's gonna hit my guys all, but...
I'm good.
Watch out for that.
Oh, no.
Oh, he's one, too.
Wait, I didn't even hear it.
Wow.
That was about to be a crazy old.
After reload.
What the?
I'm okay.
Okay, maybe we should...
getting your life steal crazy oh i'm still alive but i think
that's it for us wait we have another boost we have a lot of
time we have a lot of time we can win this we can win this
there are lucio combo we have another boostio combo yes we
have a boostio coming in no no cork you man we gotta at
least win it right now no no you can have it it's fine we
have kyle's all too just go here kyle kyle come here come
here and all Come back.
You come to a safe area.
Come back.
Come safely.
Oh, no.
No, I tried to save him.
He was not safe at all.
I don't know if you use your alt yet.
Have you used your alt yet?
No.
It's okay.
Okay.
So you got go safe and then all right.
Garg, you ready?
I'm going to let you in.
Okay.
I did say I was going to do it.
Oh, my God.
Not me.
Oh, no, I'm so I got snatched already.
Yo, Malga was one.
All right.
just ignited when you're close got it it was an empty room
sadly
no it's okay guys that's okay you know we were just too good
we had to lose at least one time yeah true that's team shine
see kyle is one of us you guys got him on overwatching
converted him my last my last living member
wait we're still here what do you mean we're still
physically yeah you're done or you you don't want to play
one more i'm gonna do one more lg lg lg lg no we gotta win
guys we gotta win this one though we already won the first
one we won two already yeah we won two and one yeah yeah
yeah you might you might be a little bit too used to you
know to winning to what yeah i don't think so that's why
we're on overwatch all right i'm ready i'm going random or y
'all want to play shambala I'm putting random we'll see how
we actually oh wait Shambali's fun actually no yay nice
yepy yuppie yuppie I don't know who I want to do I want to
play I'm gonna play the Ramatra again
He's strong.
I want to play Elari.
All right.
I'll play the Junker Queen then.
You can try hard.
I can try hard with the Junker Queen.
We got a win, guys.
This is LG.
That's what I'm saying.
Well, I do it for the boys.
If we win, we go to Orlando.
Oh, sweet.
We all just show up.
You guys go to Boys Con September 20.
It's September this year.
We all just show up in Orlando.
I'd be like, wow, what if, what's so funny seeing you guys
here?
Not Shinedo.
Wow, that's crazy.
We can ask Andy to bring us along.
Oh my God, yes.
Yeah, the Capcom boy.
Who's Andy?
Have I met him?
You have.
Was he the Asian guy with the hat?
He is.
Oh, I do know him.
I was like, wait, Andy, the Asian guy with the hat.
Okay, I remember now.
Oh, my.
Damn.
Who megaloled them for a second?
I got him.
You who megaloled Andy?
Why who megaloled them?
I can't believe I did that.
He took care of you.
He did.
He fucking brought me to the right bus in Japan and
everything.
You're like, who's Andy?
Listen, Japan was so long ago, I need another one to remind
myself.
That's what I'm saying, bro.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Next.
Next one is going to be...
Look at you pushing the car.
Nice.
Good car push.
I like that.
Oh, I think I'm about to go Kyrie.
I like how Sharky is the one that died.
Oh, God.
I am so cooked.
Yeah, I'm going to go.
You're no longer.
You're so fine.
Never mind.
Wait, they're telling me.
Was Rat Justice an auto name?
Is that what somebody just told me?
Or is that something you pick?
That's something I picked.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's from like my Starcraft days, it must be.
Whoa!
Like, it's using your Blizzard account, yeah.
Starcraft?
Like, competitively?
Or just like...
I'm trying to do something.
No, no, no.
Just, you know, like a kid playing Starcraft.
Yeah.
I'm just getting killed.
I have a king kills.
Like this guy's been stalking me.
Plus got nano.
I almost have mild too.
I'm using mild and I'm swapping to kill you.
Oh my god, bro.
They got antside.
Oh, they're antside.
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill.
they're sweaty sweaty yeah they're sweaty i don't know
what's going on
let me ask you a strategy thing like it so it makes more
sense right now to try to clear them out then try to push
the car yeah because you can't push right now because
they're just holding all the space in front of us here oh my
god yeah i can take it ready to move up hold on shine is not
ready to move up yeah i got it yeah we'll wait a little bit
wait i'm gonna use my all i'm just gonna pop it so they know
what they're doing they know yeah guys this lg might be a
little rough guys yeah this is crazy i'm just gonna pop it
or mmr went up so high from all our dubs no boys guys guys
no these guys are serious serious he literally slept me in
the air as illari these guys are like these guys are pro
come back guys we won too much we we did we should have
dialed them back we should have these guys are playing with
no money on the line right now they're more vibing they're
vibing really a lot of a big deep shield hit a big slow for
me shana we get the nano and then we're gonna fucking we're
gonna kill i'll make some space i don't have susu if that's
okay i'm absolutely Oh my god, dude.
Shine is literally dying in two seconds.
You gotta get it.
Oh my god!
No more else, no more else, no more else.
This is it.
Alright, that's what we needed.
That's what we needed.
This is what we needed.
See you guys.
Look.
Just had a combo or old slicker and giant hordes.
Come out.
We hit a level three right there, a little early in the
round.
It's alright though.
We might not have any.
Oh wait, we do have Jugrat out.
Oh, we have Rat Justice.
Alright, here we go.
Okay.
when you get your ultimate you're gonna hide back here press
it and steer the tire into them and then press left click to
detonate it it's gonna be big oh my god i was too hp i
missed my you gotta build it though maybe spam a little bit
for damage it'll build naturally slowly but you can if you
hit one more damage hit you'll be able to use your ultimate
there and it'll be great oh i was trying to get you oh no oh
there we go there we go it's huge it's huge nice you got one
that's We're like down one.
Oh, we're down two.
Okay, wait, wait, back up here.
Wait, wait, we might be close to the ladder.
High underneath, high underneath.
That's good because you got the support, so it's a good
exchange.
Are these guys here?
You guys really want to win.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, they do.
Oh, geez.
I don't have Susie, so he's going to, he might all here.
Oh, he's definitely going to all.
He's definitely going to all.
Oh my.
Oh, I'm dead.
She's...
Oh my god.
We got to touch.
Got...
I got car touch.
They put Bob on the car.
That's just no way you win that.
They put Bob on the car too.
They're so sweaty, man.
Guys, we might have tried too hard.
That can't be our...
That can't be our LG, guys.
Come on.
yeah come on that can't be our lg next look at this though
it did go fast it did go quick yeah so we could sneak up one
yeah you can do one almost i i would try this time
we were streams that's why they stream sniped us guys they
read our
it's not us it's them yeah it's okay this now is lg now
we'll get one one good one one last good one here here we go
dude they're still going they're still going they're they're
a match number eight now oh my god honestly i honestly i
don't want to go to orlando that bad i'm not gonna lie No,
but it was that close too for us too.
But it was for Japan too.
Yeah, we were playing for Japan.
Yeah, I wanted to go to Japan that bad.
I was okay with that.
You don't like Orlando?
I'm in Orlando right now, so it's not much of it.
They won't even need to pay for your flight.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
he said it's first to 80 wins is that how you win that yeah
first 80 points yeah so you basically 40 now they got a few
more to go and they have like yeah that's crazy 54 yeah and
there's double points as well so they do have a 20 pointer i
think they do like timeouts and breaks and stuff in between
so they could give strats and stuff ours ran until like 2 a
.m though like or something like that right yeah i just
remembered like it was so fucked because the moment we won
we got into the fight like what was it the moment we beat
them uh during the semis we had another finals and then we
had to fight them again right after yeah and they're like
and they were like playing and we were just waiting the
whole thing oh yeah yeah i remember like they like when they
we had to reset the round i had to play uh against the aki
like twice in a row and i was so tired by now.
I wanted my little time out.
Alright, oh, cheat.
Guys, you like my skin?
What's your skin?
Like my skin?
Come over here.
What is it?
How much money have you spent on Overwatch, if I see you?
Um, like, none.
Actually, like none.
What?
Oh, wait, was it Punk?
Did Punk buy it?
No.
Well, the only thing I bought was the Hello Kitty skin.
like everything else i just was it loot box i don't know i
had it for like yeah loot box Rise from like Overwatch 1
yeah yeah boxes yeah yeah yeah I couldn't tell back in the
day back when you can oh yeah I mean now they do you can do
it again yeah yeah now they're generous with it now you get
but you'll get shop skins right I don't remember I think you
do you do I don't know I don't know I I think so because I
got the One of the boxes they gave me, I got Hardboard Diva,
and I think that was in a shot.
Oh, yeah, no, it is.
That was.
A lot of the shop skins are in there, yeah.
Oh, that's nice.
You can actually get the weapon skins in it, too.
Like, hard light.
I don't know if you see the hard light ones.
Yeah, like the Reaper has a hard light.
Ryan has one.
I would never get that.
I'm not going to lie.
Every time they give me a loot box, it's like a Thor Bjorn
skin.
I'm like, what the fuck, bro?
I'm just telling you.
You got to make sure they get the swimsuit one.
That's why.
I have the one.
I have all of them.
I literally have like the one.
How much Overwatch you play for?
Oh my god.
Throw a line.
I mean, I used to play a line, then I stopped, and now I
just got back into it again.
I mean, it's making a comeback.
It is.
Yeah, I think it's better than Rivals, honestly.
I have more fun on it than Rivals right now.
There's just too much sustainability in Rivals with the
triple support.
There's no.
Yeah, it's not fun.
It's like they pop an ult and like the game is just over for
a little bit.
There's not enough neutral fights in Rivals.
It's mostly.
just everything shines yeah there's just a lot of uh alt
spam yeah it just was too much sustain agreed i say that i
also moved to rivals for a little bit but yeah me too me too
i think i i mean when we're all back i have actually i play
like both games equally because rivals is easier to solo
queue overwatch like solo queue is like i think like solo
queue support is more rough dude it's so bad yeah i agree
yeah rival solo queue support you could you don't have to
try as hard but in overwatch so if you support it feels like
you're playing like you're playing for a million dollars
yeah and i'm playing with no dps players like they're just
they're so bad every time i just don't understand also like
i will say overwatch players are a lot more mean than the
rivals player i don't know about that rivals is getting
there i've had some really toxic people but now i just don't
like the streamer mode in rivals because it's like they
literally reveal your name right after are we in queue wait
we're not in queue we're not in queue that's my bad i hit
re-q i swear i hit re-q shooting some robots we're just
shooting robots for fun that's funny i'm like hold on a
minute i was yeah i was gonna say this is a long long ass
i've been saying that for a while but i forgot i'm to myself
oh yeah i was gonna say shine's not talking i thought no one
was just listening to me i was like all right it's just like
the usual we listen to you shine we listen to you oh it's 50
50 now they're tied up damn it's going crazy shine sincerely
i think you were like a really good patient coach like i do
appreciate the sessions we had oh thank you i feel like i
feel like encouraged to like you know get back in it and
play more of the game i mean you should it's a fun game as
long as you enjoy it you should try for masters though i
would i would suggest trying out modern first and then if
you want to play like classic later you can always make the
switch like there are people that just switch the classic
later it's modern doesn't incentivize you to still use
classic input so you still actually can use them you know
yeah yeah you should try it out what i saw the other sagat
do which i think is the coolest move is where you charges up
as sure you can oh yeah yeah yeah oh is that one for classic
no no you can do it in in modern the charge dp i guess yeah
that's one of the coolest things i saw in the trailer i was
like man that looks so satisfying and it is it is very
satisfying but they're still playing man this is great it's
50 50 right no way holy it's like our game last year look at
that there's a few us have you ever played Street Fighter 6
with your trip to Orlando on the line they get to go to
Disneyland okay oh my god I think like I think they're
two-pointed or 20-pointed hotashi yeah yeah i mean because
it's like the third it's usually a third player right yeah
yeah i'm surprised it's not coney unless like the chun lee
is fucking him up right now it's because they're at 50 right
so like they need 70 so if the first two win they don't even
need to get to hotashi yeah but then they could just oh
that's true oh yeah yeah i'm like coney is i I don't know
what the Viper did differently against him.
I was just, I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck to do.
You know what, guys?
I came in knowing what to expect.
And then the day still surprised me.
The day still surprised me.
I got better more than I thought I was going to get, you
know?
oh apparently why are we actually low-key a solid overwatch
there was some a little bit of overwatch tournament drama i
saw my timeline it's the usual people just hopefully facts
people just complaining about people being too tryhard in
the in the creator tournament i mean it's money on the line
of course that's gonna happen just the usual bunch of what
they're fighting for their life for this trip to orlando and
our team chat is a bunch of legit codes in an official
capcon game server yeah
you got those vices i know i don't i think they will
appreciate that we are bonding after this you know exactly
yeah we are friendship exactly oh and again got this oh oh
oh what's going on i'm terrible actually i'm gonna get him
dude him wow shine playing tank and death match wow that's
what i'm saying like what is that yeah what is this what is
the issue oh we got a game all right we have to win this you
broke the i can only play tank when you guys want me to play
tank yeah yes yes i see i wish we get like a page oh an
escort map we're gonna get lejeune tower is good bro yeah
it's a classic thank god oh thank god
all right all right we we try and wait i have an idea now
we're trying we dabbing hard pocket car queue and then
that's the win con oh yes the the perfect duo let's go we're
getting that
don't worry i'm gonna spin my gun until we win let me see
what skin you got on the win con right here yeah you are a
mercy main what you mean oh because i have the bunny yeah i
bought the bunny you gotta change your name yeah you gotta
change your name to bunny also be the ultimate mercy you see
my the colon three too i got i got the pure larp here yeah
but i took off the golden gun because i was too embarrassed
i have a golden gun for all supports but i purposely took it
off on mercy okay okay there we go look at that that's one
oh oh no they bought raw justice off the map yeah this this
has a little bit of uh environmental hazards on this map oh
feisty i slept someone as i got he's coming for you there
you go shine nice okay i got the flash oh oh that's right oh
no he's alive i kill his hog oh yeah that lucio maybe we
shouldn't have chose this map how do you count it like what
do you do you just jump uh you just have to know the map
that yeah you just have to get off the other way all right
no more edges for me Yeah, that's that face.
I mean, honestly, yeah, that's basically the strat.
My god.
You could also go the right side.
We could go the right side, guys.
Yeah, the area is a little bit safer.
Do we got a dog?
Why don't we go the other side, guys?
We can go the other way, yeah.
I wasn't getting bumped up.
I'm just seeing.
Oh, yeah.
Just on by yourself.
Careful.
They're coming for you, Kyle.
Back up.
I'm coming to help you.
Got to help.
Come and help you.
We're here.
I got you.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I don't have Flash Hill anymore.
He used it on Kyle.
It's okay.
The Lucio can't hurt us anymore.
I'm going for this Lucio.
Where is he?
I can ult this.
The Woodhog is behind us.
Oh, he's there.
He's so far away.
I don't worry about it.
I got Bob.
We're going in.
We're going in with this.
I got Bob for us.
That'll be our zoning tool.
Damn, I wish I could nano the Bob.
Oh.
Oh, nicely.
Oh, massive.
Oh.
Oh, no.
There's a hog coming in.
I'm a little scared about that hog.
That hog is gaming like his life is on the line right now.
Yeah, they're anti-bear.
Oh, big, big, big.
Ooh.
It's all right.
Kirk, you, I've got you.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I don't have you anymore.
Oh, oh, shit.
Nice.
That's a good.
That's a huge.
That's huge.
Go, Shine.
do something give him all the time when the map you gotta be
kidding me i wasn't looking at the time you know oh my god
just like Me and street fighting.
China's drunk.
I wasn't looking at the time.
Moving around, bro, this is Syrian.
Yeah, this is LG.
Yeah, what?
We pulled out all the stops.
Now we're on cast mercy.
We are desperate for this win.
We're desperate.
We're pushing that.
And you're not even paying attention.
No, I was.
I was.
It's just not.
No, it's a timer.
I was panicked.
I'm nervous.
In quick play?
It's LG in quick play.
Oh, whoa.
He's anteed.
Nice.
I got the squishies.
You go for it.
I'm going all the way around.
You just keep shine alive.
That's it.
There we go.
There's the Lucio out in the open behind.
Nice.
Is he doing Lucio things?
Yeah, he's doing, he's, he's gone, gone now.
Wait.
Yeah, we want this win.
Yeah.
We want it.
We just want it more.
We want this more.
We're literally pulling all the stops.
We are.
More faded, more faded.
I'm going for her.
Oh my God, the hard comms.
Set, chap one car queue right now.
That's me.
That's me right there.
Oh, you know me.
DPS player.
Yeah, that's what you're most known for.
Exactly.
Whoa, what?
Who's making people sleep?
He's one.
Oh, Arana.
That's nice.
That's fun.
Oh.
I'm rising.
Don't worry.
You're born again?
I can't.
It's like you never died.
Oh, we gotta save Shad.
I got you, Shad.
You gotta peek us, though.
it's okay it's okay no blue nice dead that's right no red
lucio for you oh no i need help i think you're dead i got
you i gave you a little extra boost thank you it's all right
why is this okay flash shield
we're doing it guys they might have a whole hog here i think
they have everything they don't have they didn't use any all
it's okay i have mano i will nano shine or something yeah i
have my old actually shine you're getting yes oh here that's
fine oh god nice nice how you got man he got hooked that's
okay hold the space down there yeah yeah yeah yeah don't
worry i gave you flash healers you got this oh my god Help
on the point on the point.
Oh, they're solo.
It's just them.
Look at that.
Look at them go look at us Look at us.
We want this.
We want this so bad
Hey, look at that I fuck with their videos, but I gotta send
tomatoes at you You know that they cast mercy let us I'm
gonna say hey man and he'll add you as a friend
wait big yes
wait he will duo with you We will use car Q as collateral.
On collateral.
Somebody get lose you.
Wait a minute.
They're trying.
Oh, he got me.
He rolled me.
Beat his ass.
No, he had.
If he didn't have health back.
If he didn't have it.
I literally hit every shot that mattered.
god karku you should have you should have added them as a
friend you know you should have accepted adding them as a
friend it's the bad karma for yeah for deflecting i'm gonna
type in like he won't do it if you we lose bro yeah don't
join a vc for this guy oh you're still it's okay i had Nice,
nice, nice.
We got Lucia.
We got two.
We're out.
We're going out.
Go in.
Oh, but.
Oh, wait.
Don't wake him up.
Oh, my bad.
That's okay.
We got to go on point.
We're going point now.
Oh, Kyle.
Well, Kyle's already ahead of the game.
Kyle, we got you.
We got you.
Kill him.
Nice.
Wait, Lucia's coming in.
I hear him.
Nice.
That's right.
I have low here.
They're salty.
They're so salty.
They're so mad.
Behind us?
Oh, my God.
Help.
You okay?
I got you.
Shooting, shooting, shooting.
You can play on, you can back out to point here.
I'm going to let this for us.
All right, shine, go.
Yeah, I got you a damage boost too.
Oh, I like that.
That's big.
Oh, that's big.
Oh, no, that's no.
Oh, no.
No, it's okay.
He wasted it.
Did he waste it?
Did he?
Okay, he wasted it.
We're good.
We're so healthy.
That's an insane poll.
We're chilling.
We're so chilling right now.
We're so hot, guys.
Shine is so dead too.
I literally used to...
I'm good.
Trust.
Shoot the soldier top right.
Oh my god, they're on Kyle.
They're on Kyle.
Hope you save Kyle.
Help Kyle!
Mission help Kyle!
It's okay.
As long as we help Kyle.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
You can shot by a soldier Kyle.
There he goes.
I believe.
Nice shot.
I saw it.
He's low.
Get the soldier.
Let's go.
You go back in here, Faisy.
Go.
Wait, where's that Lucio?
There's that Lucio right here.
He's back here.
He's just grooving.
Yeah, he's by himself.
All right, you got what we did.
Wait, more, more, more, more.
Come on.
We need this.
We need it.
Oh, nice.
We need it more.
We need it more than Orlando.
We, I think we played hard.
Like, I think we tried harder here than Orlando.
Oh, no.
It's on the point.
Nice.
There we go.
Let's go.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, we're clapping like people clap when to blame lands,
bro.
Wait, are you joining the voice?
Come on, come on.
Everyone watch.
I'm joining.
Okay, I'm watching.
I'm listening.
That was all me, actually.
I nanoju.
Wait a minute.
Hold up.
Is he saying anything?
I don't hear anything.
Yeah, I don't hear anything.
Oh, they were pussies.
They were too scared.
That's crazy.
Wow.
I watched you as a kid.
Damn.
That's like, oh.
It happened so much.
They're like, I watched you when I was six with my dad.
And now I'm like a 15 year old teenager in fucking top 500.
And I'm like, all right, man.
Damn, you got unk status there.
I get unk'd here.
I get unk'd too much in this game.
ggs guys that was fun thanks yeah it was a great evening
with you all even though we lost a street fighter but we won
we won in front of our hearts in friendships yeah we gained
a family we gained a family we gained a family cal's gonna
invite all of us to the game awards next year joel copped
GGs, everybody.
GGs, good night.
Good night, good night.
Good night, everybody.
Bye-bye.
That was fun.
Yeah, I think we were the most fun team, guys.
Honestly, we had the most fun in the end.
And we won LG.
What more can I ask for?
Guys, what more can I ask for?
Not only on my mission today, well, not for the Overwatch
one.
I was just autopiling Overwatch.
I had a feeling like, I knew which teams were like super
stacked.
So I was just like, you know, whatever happens happens.
Because I felt like even if I practiced an Overwatch, I
think it wouldn't change anything overall.
Because like as a support, there's only so much you could do
as a support.
in Overwatch.
So I put all my hours, I literally put everything in the
street fighter.
Because I felt like I had to play catch up versus everybody
else because I was learning a new character.
I was learning a new character versus everyone was playing
what they've always played before.
Or they've had history with street like fighting games and
stuff and you know last time i typed the last time i touched
street fighter was literally like last year for this exact
tournament i didn't think i don't i don't think like what i
like what i did with honda was like you know was didn't
really necessarily carry over in mine so basically it was
like two week cram session to try and learn as much as i
could on my um for the turn i think i could have beat bricky
i personally think um i think i could the first game and
usually first game i would i like i don't do well on the
first game and also i was put on the last c2 so i was just
like i just had a lot of pressure going into it coney i was
just i didn't know what i was doing coney definitely cheesed
me in a way like i didn't know what to block because i was
just like this this combo i'm not familiar with the combo
was like fucking me up and i even though i fought 80 plus
alexes in i fought 80 plus alexes i didn't i didn't coney's
play style was very weird to the point where i just didn't
know what to do yeah and he took my side and he took my side
yeah so um so that's why i was like i was really half proud
of myself for taking that game off of ricky um because he
was the favorite in our tier and I was so proud of myself
because I know like that was his main character and and I
was able to and I was able to take a full set like we didn't
go to a third game or anything we went like 2-2 yeah I 2-0ed
and I was so happy proud of myself and everything so that
made me really really happy because I felt like all that
hard work paid off overall like I know our team might have
got last but i won my one that i didn't expect to win you
know you know i thought i was gonna i thought i was gonna be
against bricky because i know like we were both like um in
the same rank um and but i just didn't have i think i just
didn't have enough chun lee experience too yeah i i
literally barely ever see chun lee i see lots of Alex's and
I should have warmed up more with Chun-Li before uh, I
should have warmed up with with Chun-Li More before the
tournament but I was being stupid I was being I should have
went through my Chun-Li gauntlet, but I was just like fuck
it Let's just fight 20 more Alex's like That's so I forgot
the I forgot her attacks because I forgot like What I could
block and what I couldn't block.
Because I just don't play against Chun-Li a lot.
The fact that I play against Viper more than Chun-Li is so
fucked up.
Anyway, I'm super proud of myself.
Because, you know, after all those hours being put on my
waking up at 7 in the morning.
And waking up at 7 in the morning, Korea.
just grinding street fighter almost every day every other
day i think i had like i had 500 plus games on my within two
weeks i was i'm just proud of myself that i was able to i
felt like i was definitely the weakest player so uh i was
the weakest player and i was so proud of myself that i took
a game off like i literally won like won my match Against
Viper who was the fan favorite in our tier Who was like The
best player I think I see myself as the weakest because
Every player kept playing Their character but I'm always
Swapping characters and I'm always Learning new because like
new Playstyles because Zangief Honda and Mai were all
Different playstyles We're all different playstyles And like
every time I have to learn a new character I basically have
to like relearn everything from scratch so like because I
know Ricky has done two say jam slams before on Chun-Li and
I know Ricky had previous experiences on Viper too and
obviously Kony is a super like a fighting game pro so I'm
just really happy that you know I put up a good fight yeah I
went from grappler cheese to zone that's three different
play styles like
yeah so those out you don't understand i would i bashed my
head you don't i bashed my head against rank for so much i
was actually so angry that's why i was so angry in this
tournament this i was so angry practicing for street
fighting you don't understand i was so angry and the worst
part It would be like five in the morning and I'd be yelling
at my screen monitor in rank because I was so mad and I
Literally gave up in rank like last night because I was like
this is not worth it.
This is I don't want to climb anymore.
I I don't want to climb in this game anymore.
I was so mad last night I like I hit my point.
I hit my breaking point there like And that's why I was like
get in here dragons it's time to abuse it's time to abuse
you it's time to beat the abuse goblin in the basement yeah
yeah um i would be very surprised if capcom invites me again
for this tournament
i would be i was so i think this is the most angry i've ever
been in street fighter
yeah it's definitely been the most most angry guys but i am
happy it all paid off in the end i was a little bit taught
guys i think i might have been a little bit too passionate
this time around i think i might have been way too
passionate i yapped a lot i hope i wasn't too annoying i was
a big yapper today um yeah yeah just a little bit oh wait
who won let's see who won
are we free to go who won team nephew won it again team
nephew won wait a message feisty I was gonna put it in her
chat but then I was like maybe that'd be too toxic team
nephew won again back to back it's so idiot
I was a little overjoyed I just I needed a win in something
like you know the moment where like you were you were the
deciding factor like it's just it's i know it's toxic but
it's just i don't know it's like you were the deciding
factor and i was like oh my god i did this like i was i was
the deciding factor in Orlando finally I'm important guys
important it's called being competitive exactly guys exactly
I don't remember who was on nephew's team at oh bra pro
right bra pro oh I'm not wait oh Kony didn't get it it was
bra pro Mitch Bricky and Blood Thunder you know what good
for Bricky he got uh couldn't play this looks like have been
us why didn't nef why didn't nephew pick us again i'm so sad
he hates us i'm joking jk jk it's just banter is this me and
feisty bantering chime was a great coach guys no he was i
think like shine was good chemistry with like you know we
had good chemistry with shine um he was a good sport of or
everything you know like um and uh we were we you know
everyone had a great time everyone everyone just had like
you know we might have lost but we all had a good time you
know we could have been sad you know we could have been sad
and lost but we were happy and shine put up with me asking
him for coaching at like the craziest hours because i would
ask for him for coaching at like nine in the morning like at
like seven in the morning which would be 10 a.m for him i
would at like because i would you know i would be playing at
seven in the morning i'll be playing i'll be like please
coach i need coaching right now and then um you know uh and
he was there for us he was there for me when i asked for
additional coaching so shout out to shine for for showing up
also if i even even if i beat bricky or coney i don't think
it would have mattered in the live run i don't think points
wise points wise guys yeah no we points wise even if i beat
Ricky or Connie, like, I don't think it would have mattered.
I would have had bragging rights, guys.
True, I would have had bragging rights, but I already got my
bragging rights by beating the Viper who beat everyone else.
I already got my bragging rights, guys.
yeah you know what because i was like uh i was like stalking
people's are my tears profile the viper player was literally
hard labbing against coney um i saw it i saw his because i
you know i i like scouting out the competition and um um and
uh i saw i saw the viper hard labbing against like his
practice so he didn't see me as competition and that was his
mistake he underestimated me and that didn't pay off in the
end with that underestimation as underestimation yeah he
they They love the fools.
True.
Anyways, I'll, I'll, maybe, I mean, I feel like I'm
improving every time.
I usually just play Street Fighter whenever like my time,
whenever I plot, like whenever I get picked for a team.
So maybe, maybe next time.
Beware the coughing baby.
It was like always a mentality thing, but I was like, same
mentality going it like for bricky i was like being like i
could do this and then like coney i was just like i cannot
do this and then viper was just like well i can't do this
but fuck it like i'm just gonna vibe bricky i went and i was
just nervous just because like uh uh just because like i
said it's always first match first match i need to get it
out of the system like for the first match and i think if i
wasn't the last match going in it would have been better um
but i was still trying i was like trying but it was still
first match so obviously i wasn't making the right decisions
and then second match i was just like i don't know guys and
the third match i was like ah he peconi guys but i i got it
in the end
it right always works yeah um but yeah thank you everyone
for watching my two back-to-back tournaments next week we
have i don't even know that i don't i can't announce it yet
but next week we have brawl pro instantly put out marvel
rivals after winning the tournament brawl pro is now playing
marvel rivals
right after he needs to blends himself.
But what was I saying?
After all that, he's back at it.
He's back at it again.
What was I saying?
I just thought it was so funny seeing like, Bravo is now
playing Marvel Rivals.
Oh yeah, next week we have two tournaments.
Well, we have one tournament and I realized I got confused.
We have a tournament.
next week and another tournament the week after i can't say
what the tournament is for next week because they told me
that they won announce it first um so i mean i feel like you
could predict it just look at if you look at social media
you'll know what the tournament is if you if you look at
social media you'll know what the tournament is it's it's
pretty it's a pretty big tournament yeah i was very
surprised that they sent me an email about it um i really
appreciate the opportunity
we're uniting again we're we're we're gonna i don't know
we're gonna i don't know i don't know we're gonna do well
but uh but it's a very big tournament and in the week after
that it's an apex tournament uh i got invited to an apex
tournament um so we'll see how it goes yeah uh i can say
what the week the 30th would be it would be the apex and
then the week before is a tournament i can't say yet until
they announce the participants um anyway guys as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get him around to get
that blood flowing and he said for me head to bed cause you
deserve it thank you everybody again for all the support uh
on today's tournaments the double tournaments um i had a lot
of fun um as uh had a lot of fun as always um i hope i
wasn't too mean like i was just bantering but i don't know
people like people that's like you know sometimes i met some
people first time i really realized it was just you know
banters and stuff just me like for just just fucking around
you know because on overwatch i didn't i i was also i was
also uh might be pushing it a little too
i had guys no you don't understand i really did have uh i
had a lot of rage in me guys i i wish i was I was so mad.
I was so mad.
Practicing for straight fighting.
So I hope it didn't...
I hope...
I hope it didn't go too hard.
Leaked out in Overwatch too hard.
My passion was going crazy.
No.
I think Street Fighter just does something to me.
It really does.
Anyway, guys, I'll find out what I've been talking about.
Anyway, guys, I'll see you guys later.
Thank you again, everyone, for watching.
Bye-bye, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Secret ending.
Huge shout out to Capcom again for the invite.
Huge shout out to Bougar for the invite.
That's really it.
I really always appreciate all these opportunities,
everybody.
So, yeah.
Bye-bye.
Thank you, guys.
Say thank you to Capcom.
and um capcom and overwatch slash bogey for the invites to
the tournaments yay bye actually mike want to grind
overwatch again do i have a street fight up um i don't know
i don't get i don't know that i don't think i don't know
guys hey guys bye bye